Thank you for listening to The Rest is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is the restishistory.com. In the distant plain lies Florence, pink and gray and brown, with the ruddy, huge dome of the cathedral dominating its center like a captive balloon, and flanked on the right by the smaller bulb of the Medici chapel, and on the left by the airy tower of the Palazzo Vecchio. After nine months of familiarity with this panorama, I still think that this is the fairest picture on our planet, the most enchanting to look upon, the most satisfying to the eye
感谢收听《历史的 rest》。想要获取每周独家播客、无广告收听、剧集抢先体验以及加入我们备受欢迎的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。在远处的平原上躺着佛罗伦萨，粉红、灰色和棕色交织，大教堂巨大而红润的穹顶像一个系留气球般主导着城市中心，右侧是美第奇小礼拜堂较小的球形穹顶，左侧则是旧宫轻盈的塔楼。在对这幅全景图熟悉了九个月之后，我依然认为这是我们星球上最美丽的风景，最令人赏心悦目，最能满足视觉
and the spirit. To see the sun sink down, drowned in his pink and purple and golden floods, and overwhelm Florence with tides of color that make all the sharp lines dim and faint and turn the solid city into a city of dreams, is a sight to stir the coldest nature and make a sympathetic one drunk with ecstasy. So that Dominic was Mark Twain, I think the friend of the show, and for once he's not being rude. He's actually engaging in extravagant praise because he's writing from a house in the autumn of 1892 just outside
与心灵的享受。看着夕阳西下，淹没在粉红、紫色和金色的洪流中，用色彩的浪潮席卷佛罗伦萨，使所有锋利的线条变得昏暗而朦胧，将坚实的城市化为梦想之城，这样的景象足以激起最冷漠之人的心绪，并让富有同理心的人陶醉于狂喜之中。我想，多米尼克，马克·吐温可以说是节目的老朋友了，而且破天荒地他没有口出恶言。他实际上是在进行极力赞美，因为他在1892年秋天写信时正身处
Florence and he is gazing at this famously most beautiful of cities. And I guess there he is capturing the romance and the poetry and the glory of the place that many people would say is indeed the most beautiful city on the face of the earth. Yeah, a city Tom that I think has become the embodiment of elegance, of beauty, of human achievement, I guess. So every year, you know, hundreds of thousands, millions of people go to see its cathedral and its churches and museums. The artworks in the center of Florence, things like Michelangelo's David or
佛罗伦萨郊外的一栋房子里，凝视着这座以最美丽闻名的城市。我想，他在那里捕捉到了这个地方的浪漫、诗意和荣耀，许多人会说，这里确实是地球上面对的最美丽的城市。是的，汤姆，我认为这座城市已经成为了优雅、美感和人类成就的化身。所以每年，你知道，成千上万、数以百万计的人去参观它的教堂、修道院和博物馆。佛罗伦萨市中心的艺术品，比如米开朗琪罗的《大卫》或
Botticelli's birth of Venus, the great treasures of the Uffizi, they're seen as high points, aren't they, of human culture. So you chose Twain for the introduction, but I think I would have gone for maybe some lines from the second greatest film ever made, which is of course A Room with a View, in which the character Eleanor Laveesh is talking to Helena Bonham Carter, who's gone there as a tourist. And Helena Bonham Carter has fallen in love with Julian Sands, who is now very sadly dead. And she cries out, a young girl transfigured by Italy. And why shouldn't she be transfigured? It happened to the Goths. And that's very much the vibe, isn't it?
波提切利的《维纳斯的诞生》，乌菲兹美术馆的伟大宝藏，它们被视为人类文化的巅峰，对吧？所以你在引言中选择了吐温，但我认为我可能会引用有史以来第二伟大的电影中的一些台词，也就是当然的《看得见风景的房间》，其中角色埃莉诺·拉维什正在跟海伦娜·伯翰·卡特说话，后者作为游客去了那里。而海伦娜·伯翰·卡特爱上了朱利安·桑兹，后者现在非常不幸地已经去世了。她大声呼喊，一个被意大利改变了模样的年轻女孩。她为什么不该被改变模样呢？哥特人也经历过。这非常有那种氛围，不是吗？
It is. Even Goths can be transfigured. Yeah, you're right, Tom. But the period in which Florence has become synonymous actually comes long after the Goths, doesn't it? It's the Renaissance in the 14th and 15th centuries. So the period when Italians are embracing humanism, there's a rediscovery of classical art and literature, there's a sort of spirit of curiosity and self-confidence. And one family, above all, I think has become the embodiment of Florence's wealth and glory. And they are the people who are often seen as the architects or the sponsors of this
确实。连哥特人都能被改变模样。是的，你说得对，汤姆。但佛罗伦萨成为代名词的时期，其实远在哥特人之后，对吧？那是14世纪和15世纪的文艺复兴。因此，那是意大利人拥抱人文主义的时期，古典艺术和文学被重新发现，有一种好奇心和自信心的精神。而我认为，有一个家族超越一切，成为了佛罗伦萨财富与荣耀的化身。他们通常被视为这一
new age of inquiry, this new age of artistic expression. And Twain mentioned them, didn't he, in that passage? They are, of course, the Medici. So in this series, we're going to meet them at their zenith in the 15th century, the high point of Florentine power, and some people would say say Renaissance culture. And I thought it would be fun to concentrate on three characters above all. So one of them is Cosimo de' Medici. So he's a banker, wily banker who makes himself master of the city. He's very much your kind of man, isn't he?
探索新时代、艺术表达新时代的建筑师或赞助人。吐温在那段文字中提到了他们，不是吗？他们当然就是美第奇家族。所以在这个系列中，我们将会在15世纪的巅峰时期——佛罗伦萨权力的最高点，也是有些人所说的文艺复兴文化的巅峰——与他们相遇。我觉得重点关注其中三个人物会很有趣。其中一位是科西莫·德·美第奇。他是一位银行家，精明的银行家，把自己变成了城市的掌控者。他非常符合你喜欢的那种人，不是吗？
I like Cosimo. Yeah, I think he's great. Number two, who I'm less keen on, I think it's fair to say, is his grandson, Lorenzo the Magnificent. So he's seen as the great statesman and a patron of the arts, and his life is a really kind of bonkers story, all kinds of conspiracies and twists and assassination attempts. And then the third man, who I feel is much more your kind of man, is the man who kind of succeeds them as master of Florence. And this is a monk called Girolamo Savonarola who tries to purify the city with a sort of flame of
我喜欢科西莫。是的，我觉得他很棒。第二位，坦白说我没那么喜欢，我认为是他的孙子，伟大的洛伦佐。他被视为伟大的政治家和艺术赞助人，他的人生真是一个疯狂的故事，充满了各种阴谋、转折和暗杀未遂。然后第三个人，我觉得更符合你喜欢的那种类型，是继他们之后成为佛罗伦萨主宰的人。这是一位名叫吉罗拉莫·萨沃纳罗拉的修士，他试图用一种福音派热情的烈火来净化这座城市。
evangelical zeal. The bonfire of the vanities, isn't it? Yeah, bonfire of the vanities. He himself comes to a fiery end, I think it's fair to say. So all in all, I think it's actually one of the most dazzling stories we've ever done on the rest of this history. It's full of melodramatic twists, but also full of great art, great culture, and bad behavior. So it's the perfect combination.
虚荣之火，对吧？是的，虚荣之火。他自己最终也落得个烈火焚身的结局，我觉得这样说挺公允的。总而言之，我认为这实际上是我们做过的关于《历史的rest》最耀眼的故事之一。它充满了情节剧般的转折，但也充满了伟大的艺术、伟大的文化和糟糕的行为。所以这是完美的结合。
So shall we kick off with Cosimo, Cosimo de' Medici. He's born in September 1389. So to put this into some context for the listeners, we're about 40 years after the Black Death and we're about 40 years after the Black Death, and we're about a century before Columbus sails to the New World. And Florence is going to be a big character in this story, so let's talk a little bit about Florence. You've been to Florence, obviously, Tom, haven't you?
那么我们从科西莫开始吧，科西莫·德·美第奇。他出生于1389年9月。为了给听众提供一些背景，我们大约处于黑死病爆发40年之后，我们大约处于黑死病爆发40年之后，而距离哥伦布航行到新大陆大约有一个世纪。佛罗伦萨将成为这个故事中的一个重要角色，所以让我们稍微谈谈佛罗伦萨。汤姆，你显然去过佛罗伦萨，对吧？
You've been to the Uffizi. You went on a private tour. Oh yes, one adores going to Florence. Forense, as I call it. So to give you people a bit of backstory about Florence, for a long time, Florence was just an obscure market town on the banks of the river Arno in the heart of Tuscany, but from the 12th century onwards, it underwent this explosive growth. And that was because of two things.
你去过乌菲兹美术馆。你参加过私人导览。哦，是的，人们对去佛罗伦萨趋之若鹜。Forense，正如我所叫的那样。为了给各位提供一些关于佛罗伦萨的背景故事，很长一段时间里，佛罗伦萨只是托斯卡纳中心阿尔诺河畔的一个不知名集镇，但从12世纪开始，它经历了几近爆炸式的增长。这是因为两件事。
One was cloth and the other was credit. So cloth, it's basically wool and it's imported from across Europe, but especially from England. And then when it gets to Florence, it's kind of processed and turned into cheap cloth. And about a third of Florence's population works in cloth factories on all this. So England is basically Florence is India. Yes, I guess so. That's a nice comparison.
一是布匹，二是信贷。布匹基本上就是羊毛，从全欧洲进口，尤其是从英国进口。然后当它到达佛罗伦萨后，会被加工并变成廉价布匹。大约三分之一的佛罗伦萨人口在布匹工厂里从事所有这些工作。所以英国基本上就是佛罗伦萨的印度。是的，我想是的。这是一个很好的比喻。
And then they take the money they get, the profits from all this, and they use that to kickstart a financial revolution. So this is the other thing, which is credit. So the Florentines start doing things like they use Arabic numerals instead of Roman numerals. And Arabic numerals make it easy to do complicated calculations like interest payments because they have the concept of zero. They're also using paper rather than parchment.
然后他们把赚到的钱，也就是这一切带来的利润，拿来启动一场金融革命。所以这就是第二件事，即信贷。佛罗伦萨人开始做一些事情，比如他们用阿拉伯数字代替罗马数字。阿拉伯数字使利息支付等复杂的计算变得容易，因为他们有了零的概念。他们还在使用纸张而不是羊皮纸。
So that's also been introduced by the Arabs, hasn't it? Exactly. And paper is about half the cost of parchment. So I know this is a very strange thing to say, but they lead the world in bookkeeping and accountancy because they've got this cheap paper and they've got these nice new numerals. And that's something that's often forgotten about Florence, isn't it? That as well as being the home of Dante and Boccaccio and Botticelli and Brunelleschi. It's also the home of accountancy.
这也是由阿拉伯人引入的，对吧？完全正确。而且纸张的成本大约是羊皮纸的一半。所以我知道这听起来很奇怪，但他们在簿记和会计方面处于世界领先地位，因为他们有了这种廉价纸张和这些漂亮的数字新符号。而这往往是关于佛罗伦萨常常被遗忘的一点，对吧？除了作为但丁、薄伽丘、波提切利和布鲁内莱斯基的故乡之外。它也是会计学的故乡。
Well, that's what all the culture is founded on. You know, no accountancy, no culture. So for example, it's the Florentines who invent something called the double entry. And that means you have two columns in your accounts book. One is debit and one is credit. And it's very easy to check a customer's account and all accountants will be familiar with that. So by the beginning of the 14th century, the Florentines have become bankers to Europe
嗯，这就是所有文化赖以建立的基础。你知道，没有会计，就没有文化。例如，正是佛罗伦萨人发明了一种叫做复式记账法的东西。这意味着你的账簿里有两列。一列是借方，一列是贷方。检查客户的账户非常容易，所有会计师都会对此感到熟悉。因此，到14世纪初，佛罗伦萨人已经成为了欧洲的银行家
and they are not just changing money, so they're exchanging one currency for another, but they're lending it at interest. And the symbol of their success is the Florin named after the city. The Florin is a little coin stamped with a lily, the symbol of the city. And it is recognized not just in Italy, but across the continent as a symbol of financial stability. And I guess there is one other kind of symbol that emerges in this period that of course Twain would have seen that visitors to the city now see, and that's the cathedral, the
他们不仅在兑换货币，也就是将一种货币兑换成另一种货币，而且还在放贷收息。他们成功的象征是以城市命名的弗罗林金币。弗罗林是一枚印有百合花（该市象征）的小硬币。它不仅在意大利，而且在整个欧洲大陆都被公认为金融稳定的象征。我想在这段时期还出现了一种其他的象征，吐温当然见过，现在来这座城市的游客也能看到，那就是大教堂，
Duomo, which is being built throughout this early period, isn't it? Throughout Cosimo's life. So it's begun, I think, at the end of the 13th century, and it's built throughout the 14th century, and it's on a massive, massive scale. And so it gets paused by the Black Death, very much as the similarly huge cathedral in Florence's great rival, Siena, gets paused. But Florence does have the kind of the muscle to carry on, I suppose, because it has the Florence, because it has the wealth, because it has all the accountants and everything. And by the end of the 14th century, everything's been completed apart from the dome. And the
主教堂（Duomo），它在整个早期都在建造，对吧？贯穿了科西莫的一生。所以我想它始于13世纪末，并在整个14世纪一直在建造，其规模极其宏大。因此它的建造由于黑死病而暂停了，非常类似于佛罗伦萨的伟大对手锡耶纳那座同样巨大的大教堂的暂停。但我想佛罗伦萨确实有能力坚持下去，因为它拥有弗罗林金币，因为它拥有财富，因为它拥有所有的会计师和一切。到14世纪末，除了穹顶之外，一切都已完工。而
challenge with the dome is it's going to have to be on such a massive scale But nobody's quite sure how to do it Yeah, they kind of draw up a plan for a dome that is going to be modeled on Roman Exemplar but it's going to be kind of radically different But nobody's quite sure how to build it and in the long run someone will come up with a wheeze for how to build it But I guess it's providing a kind of backdrop to the events that you're going to be describing. This massive, not yet completed cathedral, but the idea of building this dome is going to be something that's never been seen before, but also rooted in the classical past. And I guess that's kind
穹顶面临的挑战是它的规模必须如此宏大，但没有人完全确定该怎么做。是的，他们为穹顶拟定了一个蓝图，其造型将以罗马范例为模本，但又会有所根本不同。然而没有人确信该如何建造它，从长远来看，总会有人想出一个建造它的妙招。但我想它为你即将描述的事件提供了一种背景。这座巨大的、尚未完工的大教堂，但建造这个穹顶的想法将是前所未见的，同时也植根于古典过去。我想这某种程度上是佛罗伦萨精髓的象征，对吧？
of emblematic of what Florence is all about, isn't it? I think that's absolutely right. I think a lot of the action that we're going to be describing this year is actually takes place in the cathedral, including the kind of altar of the cathedral. And you mentioned how big it is. So the cathedral capacity is about 30,000 people. I mean, that's extraordinary. Now at its height, Florence had about 100,000 people. So this is because it sucked in people from the countryside because of the cloth industry. Then the Black Death happens and it shrinks to about 50,000. So remember, the cathedral seats, or rather you stand, 30,000. That gives you a sense of just how important the cathedral is in the life of the city. So you could imagine they could have abandoned the cathedral like the Sienese do, but I guess
我认为完全正确。我认为我们今年将要描述的许多情节实际上都发生在主教堂内，包括主教堂的祭坛之类。你提到了它有多大。所以大教堂的容量大约是3万名。我的天，这太非同寻常了。而在其鼎盛时期，佛罗伦萨大约有10万人口。这是因为它由于呢绒工业而从乡村吸引了大量人口。然后黑死病爆发了，人口缩减至大约5万人。所以请记住，大教堂可容纳，或者说你可以站立的座位，是3万个。这让你对大教堂在城市生活中的重要性有了概念。所以你可以想象他们本可以像锡耶纳人那样放弃大教堂，但我想
they don't because they are confident. It's not just that they've got the money, but they're confident the city will grow again. They're looking to the future. Well, it's still one of the top five cities in Europe. So Paris, Milan, Venice, Naples are the other big players in the late 14th, early 15th century. Because Florence is such a character in the story, maybe worth giving people a sense of what it would have been like, it would take you about half an hour to walk across it and you're walking through these this sort of warren of narrow streets, which of course is still there. There's
他们没有放弃，因为他们充满自信。不仅是因为他们有钱，还因为他们坚信这座城市会再次发展。他们放眼未来。嗯，它仍然是欧洲前五大城市之一。所以在14世纪末、15世纪初，巴黎、米兰、威尼斯、那不勒斯是其他的大玩家。因为佛罗伦萨是故事中的一个大角色，也许值得让人们感受一下它本来的面目，你大约需要花半小时才能穿过它，你走过这些犹如迷宫般的狭窄街道，当然这些街道现在依然还在。有
great stone palaces, the palazzi, the churches, there are loads of shops because it's a very commercial place. There's a lovely description by a historian called Donald Weinstein and he's writing about what it would have been like and he says, you know, crowded with people in doublet and hose, silk-gowned ladies, long-robed clerics, laborers, beggars, hawkers, cut purses, flesh peddlers, and gangs of rowdy youths. And we'll come to some gangs of rowdy youths later in the series. And there's something else actually which we never think about in Renaissance Florence. There would have been thousands of slaves.
宏大的石头宫殿、官邸（palazzi）、教堂，有许许多多的店铺，因为它是一个非常商业化的中心。历史学家唐纳德·温斯坦有一段精彩的描述，他谈到当时的景象时说，你知道，到处挤满了穿着紧身衣和长袜的人、身穿丝绸长裙的贵妇、身披长袍的神职人员、劳工、乞丐、小贩、扒手、皮条客，以及成群结队的喧闹青年。我们将在本系列的后面部分谈到一些喧闹的青年帮派。事实上，还有一件事我们在文艺复兴时期的佛罗伦萨从未考虑到。这里曾有成千上万的奴隶。
And these slaves were usually young girls or young women, Greeks, Turks, Circassians from the Caucasus. And it was very, very common for these rich Florentine bankers to have slave girls with whom they would sleep, actually, sort of effectively sex slaves. Cosimo will have a son by a Circassian slave girl, won't he? He will indeed. Now, cities politics, let's talk about that. Remember, Italy is not, I mean, I know you know this, Tom, Italy is not united. It's a patchwork of kingdoms and duchies and city states and so on. And Florence is relatively unusual because it's a republic. It's been a republic since the 12th century.
而这些奴隶通常是年轻女孩或年轻女性，有希腊人、土耳其人、来自高加索的切尔克斯人。这些富有的佛罗伦萨银行家拥有与他们同寝的奴隶女孩，实际上类似于性奴，这是非常非常普遍的。科西莫会和一个切尔克斯奴隶女孩生下一个儿子，不是吗？他确实会。现在，城市的政治，让我们来谈谈这个。请记住，意大利并不是——我知道你知道这一点，汤姆——意大利并不是统一的。它是由王国、公国、城邦等拼凑而成的。而佛罗伦萨相对来说很不寻常，因为它是一个共和国。自12世纪以来它一直是一个共和国。
And power, again, interestingly, resides with the mercantile elite, not the old landowning nobility. The landowning nobility are formally excluded from power. So the way the elections work is very complicated. Basically, you have to belong to one of these trade guilds, and every two months there is an election. And it's not an election where you vote. It's an election for the city council, which is called the Signoria. And basically, the names of everybody in these guilds is put into eight leather bags and they draw them out supposedly at random. So it's a kind of cross between ancient Rome and ancient Athens.
权力，同样有趣的是，掌握在商界精英手中，而不是旧的地主贵族手中。地主贵族被正式排挤出权力核心。所以选举的运作方式非常复杂。基本上，你必须属于这些贸易行会之一，并且每两个月就会举行一次选举。这不是那种你投票的选举。这是为城市议会（被称为“领主委员会/Signoria”）举行的选举。基本上，所有人行会中每个人的名字都被放入八个皮革袋里，然后他们据称随机抽取。所以这有点介于古罗马和古希腊雅典之间。
Yes, I guess so. Or a cross between an election and the draw of the national lottery. That's another way of putting it. Eight of these names that are pulled out become priori or councillors and the ninth becomes the standard bearer of the city, the gonfalonieri, and he chairs the council, the standard bearer. And all of them, when your name is pulled out, you have to move into the big stone city hall, which is of course still there in the centre of Florence, the Palazzo della Signoria. You move in there and you have servants, you have a buffoon who tells you stories and jokes and stuff.
是的，我想是的。或者介于选举和国家彩票开奖之间。换一种说法。被抽出的这八个名字成为“优先官”或议员，第九个则成为城市的旗手（gonfalonieri），他主持议会，即旗手。所有这些人在你的名字被抽中时，都必须搬进巨大的石头市政厅，当然它现在依然在佛罗伦萨的市中心，即领主宫（Palazzo della Signoria）。你搬进那里，有仆人，还有一个给你讲故事、讲笑话等等的小丑。
You're there for two months. So your term is only two months and then you're out again. And the point is to stop any one faction having too much power. And so that again is very reminiscent of the way the consuls function in ancient Rome. And generally there is an anxiety as there was in the Roman Republic about great powerful men seizing power. I'm right that actually the nobility, if you become a nobleman you're not eligible for office. So in a way it kind of becomes a punishment to become a noble is to be deprived of the chance of political office. There are lots of advisory councils and things which you probably don't need to go into, but one thing worth mentioning is what happens in an emergency.
你在那里待两个月。所以你的任期只有两个月，然后你就要离开。其目的就是为了防止任何单一派系拥有过多的权力。所以这再次让人联想到古罗马执政官的运作方式。总的来说，人们对有权势的大人物夺取权力抱有一种焦虑，就像在罗马共和国时期一样。我说的没错吧，实际上贵族阶层，如果你成为贵族，你就没有资格担任公职。所以在某种程度，成为贵族几乎变成了一种惩罚，也就是被剥夺了担任政治公职的机会。有很多咨询委员会之类的事情，你可能不需要深入探讨，但有一件值得一提的事是紧急情况下的应对措施。
In an emergency, the council will ring the great bell of the Palazzo della Signoria, which is called the Vaca. It's kind of called the cow bell because it's meant to sound like a cow mooing. Does it? I don't think it probably does. I don't think a cow would sound like a bell, but there you go. All male citizens then have to kind of pour into the Piazza della Signoria, and they hold what's called a parlamento, a parliament. And there they elect a kind of emergency committee called a balia,
在紧急情况下，议会将敲响领主宫的大钟，这座钟被称为“奶牛钟”（Vaca）。它有点被称为奶牛钟，是因为它听起来应该像奶牛在哞哞叫。是这样吗？我想它大概不是吧。我不认为一头奶牛听起来会像一口钟，但事实就是如此。然后所有男性公民都必须涌入领主广场（Piazza della Signoria），他们会举行所谓的公民大会（parlamento）。在那里，他们选出一个名为“委员会”（balia）的应急委员会，
which has kind of powers to deal with the crisis. And we'll see people doing this again and again in this story. Now, it's quite a complicated system, all this business about drawing names out of bags and whatnot, but the Florentines think it's brilliant. They boast, you mentioned Rome and Athens, they boast of their descent. They say, we are the daughter of Rome. They have a very Roman culture in some ways, or a culture that they think is modeled on the Romans. They say, we're very hardworking, we're very serious, duty and responsibility are
它拥有应对危机的某种权力。在本故事中，我们会看到人们一次又一次地这样做。现在，这个从袋子里抽名字之类的系统相当复杂，但佛罗伦萨人认为它棒极了。他们吹嘘——你提到了罗马和雅典——他们吹嘘自己的血统。他们说，我们是罗马的女儿。他们在某些方面有着非常罗马化的文化，或者说他们认为是以罗马人为模范的文化。他们说，我们非常勤奋，我们非常严肃，职责和责任对我们来说
terribly important to us. They sort of boast, you know, we bring up our children not to hunt and to hawk, this is a bit of an exaggeration by the way, but to fill in ledgers and to do sums and to make money because that's the sinews of our power. And they love all this kind of stuff. That's why the great dome of the Duomo is the perfect symbol because it's simultaneously Roman but also very distinctively Florentine and I guess the Florentines would be absolutely delighted to think of that. I mean that's what they're about. They don't want to kind of ape Rome completely but they want to dignify their own system.
极其重要。他们有点吹嘘，你知道，我们抚育我们的孩子不是去打猎和放鹰——顺便说一句，这有点夸张——而是去填写账本、做算术和赚钱，因为那是我们力量的命脉。他们热爱所有这类事情。这就是为什么大教堂的巨大穹顶是完美的象征，因为它既是罗马式的，又非常具有独特的佛罗伦萨特色，我想佛罗伦萨人会为之感到绝对的欣喜。我的意思是，这就是他们的核心所在。他们不想完全效仿罗马，但他们想要赋予他们自己的系统以尊严。
Exactly, exactly. Now by the time Cosimo was born in 1389 there were definitely tensions emerging. Number one, there's a big gap between rich and poor. The super rich, the people in the palazzi and the masses, textile workers in the slums. Number two, rather like Rome actually, Florence has expanded and it's swallowed up neighboring towns like Arezzo or San Gimignano. So that's the territory rather than the city itself. Yeah. So like Rome, Florence has expanded. So the Republic of Florence is now more than just the city. So it's swallowed up neighboring towns like San Gimignano or Larezzo.
完全正确，完全正确。现在，当科西莫于1389年出生时，紧张局势肯定已经开始显现。第一，贫富差距巨大。超级富豪，住在官邸里的人，与大众——贫民窟里的纺织工人。第二，实际上有点像罗马，佛罗伦萨已经扩张并吞并了诸如阿雷佐或圣吉米尼亚诺等邻近城镇。所以那是领土，而不是城市本身。是的。所以就像罗马一样，佛罗伦萨扩张了。因此佛罗伦萨共和国现在不仅仅是这座城市了。它吞并了诸如圣吉米尼亚诺或拉雷佐等邻近城镇。
You know, it's got a bigger hinterland now. And of course, success, as in Rome, breeds opportunities for corruption. So more and more, the rich merchant families will rig these elections. They'll rig the names in the leather bags. And there's actually, I mean, if you like kind of slightly old fashioned history books, there's a brilliant book on the Medici by Christopher Hibbert,
你知道，它现在有了更大的腹地。当然，成功就像在罗马一样，孕育了腐烂堕落的机会。越来越多的富商家族会操纵这些选举。他们会操纵皮革袋里的名字。实际上，如果你喜欢稍微老派的历史书，有一本关于美第奇家族的精彩书籍，作者是克里斯托弗·希伯特，
great popular historian of the 60s and 70s. And he says of Medici Florence, it had a government carried on mainly by the rich and almost exclusively in their own interests, which of course will in the long run create tensions as we will see in our final episode. So all of this brings us to Cosimo's own family, the Medici. So they were initially economic migrants from a place called the Magiello, which is sort of hills north of the city, and they had probably moved to Florence in about the 12th century.
60和70年代的伟大通俗历史学家。他这样评价美第奇时期的佛罗伦萨：“它的政府主要由富人运营，且几乎完全为了他们自身的利益”，这当然从长远来看会造成紧张局势，正如我们将在最后一集里看到的那样。所以所有这一切把我们带到了科西莫自己的家族，美第奇家族。他们最初是来自一个叫做马杰洛（Magiello）的地方的经济移民，那是城市以北的一些山丘，他们大概在12世纪左右搬到了佛罗伦萨。
They're famous for their coat of arms, which is red balls on a field of gold. And their supporters would often go into the streets and shout, balls, balls, in excitement. Yeah, I bet they did. Now, some people think these are kind of, the balls are kind of apothecaries, pills or cups linked to the surname of the family, Medici, which means medics, doctors. It could be pawnbrokers balls. We don't really know, but either way it's a reminder of their humble origins and the humble origins are a standing affront to the old families
他们以族徽而闻名，金底之上的红球。他们的支持者经常走上街头兴奋地高喊：“球，球！”是的，我敢打赌他们会的。现在，有些人认为这些是药剂师的丸子，或者与家族姓氏美第奇（Medici，意为医师、医生）相关的药杯。它也可能是当铺的球。我们其实并不知道，但无论哪种方式，这都是对他们卑微出身的一种提醒，而卑微出身是对佛罗伦萨老牌家族的一种长久冒犯，这些老牌家族甚至在几个世纪后仍然将美第奇视为暴发户、新贵、庸俗之辈等等。无论如何，随着时间的推移，他们一步步往上爬。他们是一个通过银行业赚钱的受人尊敬的家族。到了14世纪80年代末科西莫出生时，他们在佛罗伦萨、罗马、威尼斯、热那亚、那不勒斯等地都设有分行。由于他们的财富和成功，他们现在有了一点政治影响力，而且，你知道，美第奇亲属经常出现在
of Florence, who even centuries later see the Medici as upstarts and parvenues and vulgar and whatnot. Anyway, over time, they've worked their way up the ladder. They're a respectable family who make their money from banking. And by the time Cosimo is born in the late 1380s, they've got branches in Florence, in Rome, in Venice, in Genoa, in Naples, and so on. As a result of their wealth and their success, they now have a little bit of political clout and they are, you know, Medici relatives are often appearing in the lists
当选领主委员会（Signoria，即议会）成员的名单上。所以其中一个美第奇是投票支持布鲁内莱斯基伟大穹顶建设的董事会成员。是的，完全正确。但对于老牌家族来说，这是一个挑战。科西莫出生时，有许多人在私下抱怨美第奇太嚣张了。其中为首的是一个名为阿尔比齐（Albizzi）的家族，我们将在本集中再次谈到阿尔比齐家族。
of people who've been elected to the Signoria, to the council. So one of the Medici is on the board that votes for Brunelleschi's Great Dome. Yes, exactly. But to the old families, this is a challenge. And there are lots of people who are muttering by the time Cosimo was born that the Medici have got above themselves. The chief among these are a family called the Albizzi, and we'll come back to the Albizzi in this episode.
科西莫的父亲是一个名叫乔凡尼·迪比奇·德·美第奇（Giovanni Di Bicci Di Medici）的人。为了简便，我们称他为乔凡尼。他是一个非常非常聪明和精明的人。他主要是通过在罗马投资来建立家族企业的。罗马是佛罗伦萨银行家的庞大市场，因为佛罗伦萨的银行会为处理教皇事务、教廷事务收取高额利息。他们通过向需要建立自己权力基础的红衣主教放贷赚取了大量金钱。
Cosimo's father was a man called Giovanni Di Bicci Di Medici. We'll call him just Giovanni for short. He's a very, very smart and shrewd man. He has built up the family business above all by investing in Rome. Rome was a massive market for the Florentine bankers because Florentine banks would charge big interest rates for handling papal business, the business of the papacy. And they made a lot of money by lending to cardinals who needed to build up power bases of their own.
所以多米尼克，这段时期是阿维尼翁之囚已经结束的时期。阿维尼翁仍然有一个教皇，但教皇职位也已经返回罗马，所以出现了一种分裂。因此，所有回到罗马与教皇在一起的红衣主教显然都需要翻新他们破败的宫殿和公寓。因此需要大量的信贷。汤姆，实际上此时有两个教皇，正如我们将会看到的，有时会有三个教皇。嗯，阿维尼翁有一个，罗马有一个，是的，在适当的时候，他们会试图通过选举第三个来解决这个问题。
And so Dominic, this is the period when the Avenor exile has kind of come to an end. There's still a pope in Avenor, but the papacy has also returned to Rome and so there's a kind of split. And so all the Cardinals who have come back to Rome to be with the pope obviously need to refurbish their decayed palaces and apartments. So there's a lot of credit needed. There's actually two popes at this point, Tom, and as we'll see, there are sometimes three popes. Well, there's one in Avenue, one in Rome, and yes, in due course, they're going to try and solve it by electing a third.
还有一个四处游走的教皇。所以在14世纪90年代末，当科西莫大约10岁时，他的父亲乔凡尼对一个名叫巴尔达萨雷·科萨（Baldassare Cossa）的那不勒斯贵族下了一注极其重大的赌注，这人曾是一个海盗，但现在决定他实际上希望在天主教会中扬名立万。所以他就像劳伦斯……叫什么名字来着？布莱克本，曾当过海盗的约克大主教。真的吗？
And a roving pope. So in the late 1390s, when Cosimo is about 10, his father Giovanni makes this very, very consequential bet on an aristocrat from Naples called Baldassare Cossa, who used to be a pirate, but now decides he'd actually like to make a name for himself in the Catholic Church. So he's like Lawrence, what's his name? Blackburn, who was the Archbishop of York who'd been a pirate. Really?
我不知道这一点。嗯，这家伙科萨向美第奇借了10,000杜卡特，这确实奏效了。他首先成为红衣主教，然后在1410年他成为了教皇约翰二十三世。现在此时实际上已经有另外两个教皇了。罗马有一个，阿维尼翁有一个，而科萨并没有进入教皇的正统名单。他实际上在五年后就被废黜了。他被指控在七年里与200多名女性睡觉。现在我认为这太多了。我认为有一个黄金中庸之道，而他已经越界了。
I didn't know that. Well, this guy, Cossa, borrows 10,000 ducats from the Medici, and it works actually. He becomes Cardinal first of all, then in 1410 he becomes Pope John the 23rd. Now at this point there are actually two other Popes already. There's one in Rome and there's one in Avignon and Cossard doesn't get into the kind of canonical lists of Popes. He actually is deposed after five years. He was accused of sleeping with more than 200 women in seven years. Now I think that's too many. I think there's a happy medium and he has crossed the line.
你认为黄金中庸之道是什么样的？如果你是一个教皇，我认为在七年里有20个是合理的。你认为对于一个教皇来说什么才是合理的？三个？七年里三个。但我是这个播客的萨沃纳罗拉。我想我稍微更享乐主义一点。我的意思是，只是关于这一点的一个问题，因为他被烙上了反教皇的印记，并且基本上
What would you see the happy medium as being? If you're a pope, I think 20 in seven years is reasonable. What do you think is reasonable for a pope? Three? Three in seven years. But I'm the Savonarola of this podcast. I'm slightly more hedonistic I think. I mean just a question about this because he's branded as an anti-pope and basically
有必要给他贴上极其糟糕的标签，这样他们才能从长远上结束分裂。你认为其中可能有点夸张的成分吗？我认为可能会有一点点夸张。我确实认为，200名女性在七年里是一个很大的数字。无论如何，乔凡尼和美第奇从这家伙身上赚了很多钱，而且实际上他们建立了很多非常好的人脉。最终在1420年，他们成为了真正的教皇的银行家，这位教皇名叫马丁五世。所以那是在康斯坦茨大公会议之后，对吧？
it's necessary to brand him as being terrible so that they can in the long run end of the schism. Do you think maybe there's a little bit of exaggeration going on there? I think there may be a slight bit of exaggeration. I think 200, I do actually think 200 women in seven years is a lot. Anyway, Giovanni and the Medici made a lot of money from this bloke and actually they made a lot of really good connections. And eventually in 1420, they become the bankers for the real pope, who's called Martin V. So that's after the Council of Constance, isn't it?
他们在那里除掉了另外三个。所以此时，美第奇已经成为了佛罗伦萨最富有的人之一，而乔凡尼因此成为了一个重要的政治玩家，他多次当选领主委员会成员。这是因为他受到尊重，还是因为他在贿赂人们？我想两者兼有吧。我认为他确实受到了尊重，而且他也在进行某种程度的贿赂，其程度让我们很难通过历史的阴霾看清。或者说提供庇护更合适。庇护，是的。
Where they get rid of the other three. So at this point, the Medici have become some of the richest people in Florence and Giovanni as a result of this becomes a big political player and he is elected to the Signoria multiple times. And is that because he's respected or is it because he's bribing people? I think both actually. I think he's genuinely respected and he's bribing people to an extent that we find it hard to discern through the sort of murk of history. Or offering patronage rather. Patronage, yeah.
这种贿赂的规模并没有达到当时震惊人们的程度。我认为这被认为是完全合理的，是司空见惯的。正当这一切发生时，科西莫在被称为“老宅”（Casavecchia）的地方长大，那是佛罗伦萨市中心的一座石头美第奇宫殿。他在附近的一所修道院上学。他学习拉丁语、德语和法语。他的家庭教师是一位名叫罗伯托·德·罗西（Roberto de Rossi）的富有贵族，他是一位经典的早期人文主义学者。我们应该稍微谈谈人文主义。所以这基本上是对人文学科的研究，这意味着对古典世界的研究。所以它是语法和修辞学，但它也是哲学、所有这些种类的诗歌和艺术。而此时“人文主义”这个词本身——当科西莫大约10岁、12岁、14岁时——正在真正
It's not bribery to a scale that shocks people at the time. I think it's considered completely reasonable in part for the course. So while all this is going on, Cosimo is growing up in what's called the Casavecchia, which is the kind of stone Medici palace in the center of Florence. He goes to school as a nearby monastery. He learns Latin, German and French. His tutor is a rich patrician called Roberto de Rossi, who is a classic humanist scholar. And we should talk a little bit about humanism. So this is basically the study of the humanities and which means the study of the classical world. So it's grammar and rhetoric, but it's also philosophy and poetry and art, all of these kinds of things. And the very term humanism at this point, so when Cosimo is like 10, 12, 14, is really
突破并变得流行。要成为一名人文主义者，换句话说，去研究奥维德、柏拉图、亚里士多德等等。嗯，我觉得此时还不是柏拉图。不，汤姆，柏拉图正是在这个时候开始崭露头角的。柏拉图确实在15世纪开始崭露头角。是的，但此时有早期的迹象，我认为重要的是你需要钱，人文主义是身份地位的标志，因为大多数这些人文主义学者作为私人教师工作，他们没有体制上的
breaking through and becoming fashionable. And to become a humanist, in other words to study Ovid and Plato and Aristotle and so on. Well not I think Plato at this point. No, Plato is beginning to come through at this point, Tom. Plato is really coming through in the 15th century. Yeah, but there's the early signs of it at this point and I think the important thing is that you need money, that humanism is a sign of status because most of these humanist scholars work as private tutors, they don't have institutional
支持。换句话说，你需要能够负担得起一位私人教师，他能让你接触到所有这类学术研究。而年轻的科西莫正是那种喜欢涉足这些的人。事实上，他真的深深投入其中。所以有一本关于美第奇的好书，也是一本相当尖刻的书，作者是玛丽·霍林斯沃思（Mary Hollingsworth）。她指出，当他二十几岁快到三十岁时，有一份他家里的财产清单，其中的藏书包括西塞罗、尤利乌斯·恺撒、维吉尔、马提亚尔、奥维德、塔西陀。她说，你知道，按任何标准来看，这都是那个时期的一个大图书馆，但对于一个二十多岁且基本上是银行家而不是学者的人来说，是非常不寻常的。
backing. So in other words you need to be able to afford a private tutor who will give you access to all of this kind of scholarship. And young Cosimo is exactly the kind of person who likes to get into this. And actually he really gets into it. So there's a great book and actually quite a caustic book about the Medici by Mary Hollingsworth. And she points out that when he was in his late 20s, it was an inventory of his house and the books were things like Cicero, Julius Caesar, Virgil, Marshall, Ovid, Tacitus. And she says, you know, it's a big library for the period by any standards, but very unusual for somebody who's in their late twenties and is basically a banker, not a scholar.
多米尼克，我能顺便谈谈那个书单吗？塔西陀，我的意思是，他才刚刚被发现。所以我们知道，14世纪伟大的佛罗伦萨作家薄伽丘在读塔西陀，但没有其他人真正知道他。所以科西莫能拥有塔西陀，他真是惊人的前沿。我的意思是，他的品味几乎可以说是前卫的。是的，我想是的。我认为绝不能低估所有这些，或者说不能轻描淡写。我认为显然这是一个真正、真正对所有这一切感兴趣，并且热衷于购买最新发现的事物的人。
And Dominic, can I just pick up on that list? Tacitus, I mean, he has only just been discovered. So we know that Boccaccio, the great 14th century Florentine writer, is reading Tacitus, but nobody else really knows about him. So for Cosimo to have Tacitus, he's amazingly cutting edge. I mean, it's kind of almost avant-garde in his tastes. Yeah, I think so. I think there's no underestimating all this or sort of underplaying it. I think clearly this is somebody who is really, really interested in all this and is keen to buy the latest things that have been discovered.
你知道，渴望处于最前沿，完全正确。我们没有得到多少年轻时科西莫的 glimpses（惊鸿一瞥）。他似乎避开公众视线。据说他衣着非常朴素。他不带庞大的随从。据说他有一种简洁而冷嘲热讽的幽默感。非常严谨。我的意思是，既然你这么说了，汤姆，这里有一个明显的差异点。
You know, keen to be at the sort of cutting edge, exactly. We don't get many glimpses of Cosimo as a young man. He seems to keep out of the public eye. He's said to be very soberly dressed. He doesn't go around with a big retinue. He's said to have a kind of terse and sardonic sense of humor. It's very Sambra. I mean, now that you said that, Tom, here's a definite point of difference.
他娶了一个名叫孔泰齐娜·迪巴尔迪（Contesina Di Bardi）的女人，她来自另一个银行家族。克里斯托弗·希伯特将她描述为胖乎乎、能干且开朗。绝对能干，而且她确实能开朗，但她绝对不胖。不，我只想把这一点绝对记录在案。她确实能干，而且她确实能开朗，但她绝对不胖。不，我只想把这一点绝对记录在案。他们有两个孩子，而且正如你刚才所说，他和他的一个奴隶女孩、一个切尔克斯奴隶女孩育有一个私生子，一个名叫卡洛的儿子。这绝对是标准操作，并且这个孩子和他的合法儿子们一起抚养长大。
He marries a woman called Contesina Di Bardi, who's from another banking family. Christopher Hibber describes her as fat, capable and cheerful. Certainly capable, and she's capable of being cheerful, but she's definitely not fat. No, I just want to place that absolutely on the record. She's certainly capable and she's capable of being cheerful, but she's definitely not fat. No, I just want to place that absolutely on the record. They have two children and he also, as you said earlier, he has this illegitimate son by one of his slave girls, a Circassian slave girl, a son called Carlo. This is absolutely standard and he's brought up with his legitimate sons.
他从小就接受银行家训练。他的父亲把他派往法国和德国的分行，然后在1420年，科西莫实际上接管了家族企业。现在这个时候，美第奇银行是一个非常、非常严重的企业。它是欧洲最复杂的贸易网络之一。此时它也是一个非常复杂的政治网络。他有他的堂兄阿瓦拉多，他非常擅长经营所有这一切。你曾问过，这是贿赂吗？他们在使用贷款、礼物、人情，所有这些种类的东西。
He's trained as a banker from an early age. His father sends him to branches in France and Germany and then in 1420, Cosimo effectively takes over the family business. Now at this point, the Medici Bank is a really, really serious enterprise. It's one of the most sophisticated trade networks in Europe. It's also a very sophisticated political network by this point. He's got his cousin, Avarado, who's very good at running all this. And there you asked, is it bribery? They're using loans, gifts, favors, all of these kinds of things.
人们无法拒绝的提议。这一切都带有黑手党的气息。他们把他们的网络称为他们的 amici，他们的朋友，当他们彼此写信时，他们不会提到他们的朋友，他们只会对某人说，你知道，他是我们的朋友，但他们不会点名或深入细节。所以有一种感觉，带有一点点见不得光。我提到了玛丽·霍林斯沃思的书。在她的书中，她指出这些家族是在黑死病之后迁移到佛罗伦萨的。所以他们是新来者。他们是白手起家、有抱负的家族，并不是现有商业寡头政治的一部分。而这些人可能觉得有点
Offers people can't refuse. There is a mafia flavor to all this. They call their network their amici, their friends, and they don't refer to their friends when they're writing to each other, they will just say of somebody, you know, he's a friend of ours, but they won't kind of name him or go into details. So there is a sense, there's a kind of slight shadiness. And I mentioned Mary Hollingsworth book. In her book, she points out that these are families who have migrated to Florence after the Black Death. So they are newcomers. They are self-made aspirational families who are not part of the existing mercantile oligarchy. And these are people who perhaps feel a little
被更保守的家族冷落和排挤。所以这些人正是美第奇所吸引的对象。因此，对于一个极其富有的人来说，扮演人民之友的角色是有空间和余地的。是的。我们在古罗马看到了这一点，我们在现代美利坚共和国也看到了这一点。所以这也许是共和国运作中固有的某种东西。汤姆，我认为这里有太多与罗马共和国的相似之处。所以科西莫的父亲乔凡尼于1429年去世。有一些非常著名的话留给他在临终前。
bit snubbed and left out by the more conservative families. And so they are the people to whom the Medici are appealing. And so there is a scope for someone who is fabulously wealthy to play the part of the friend of the people. Yeah. And we see it in ancient Rome and we see it in the modern American Republic. So maybe something that is inherent within the functioning of republics perhaps. I think absolutely. There are so many parallels here with sort of the Roman Republic, I think, Tom. So Cosimo's father Giovanni dies in 1429. And there's some very famous words that are given to him on his deathbed.
乔凡尼据对科西莫说，你知道，对于被传唤到领主宫要非常警惕。等到被传唤时，当被传唤了。照你所被要求的去做。永远不要自负。永远不要骄傲。现在，他是否真的说过这话，我们不得而知。其中可能包含核心的真实成分，因为我认为在此时，晚
Giovanni is meant to have said to Cosimo, you know, be very wary about being summoned to the Palazzo della Signoria. Wait to be summoned when you are summoned. Do as you ask. Never be conceited. Never be proud. Now, whether he actually said this, we don't know. There's probably a kernel of truth in it because I think it's clear at this point, the late
1420年代，很明显美第奇的竞争对手正在把刀磨得更锋利一点。他们受够了美第奇，对他们感到焦虑，并准备选择时机发动袭击。其中首当其冲的就是我之前提到过的这个名为阿尔比齐（Albizzi）的 rival family（竞争对手家族）。阿尔比齐家族也是一个商业家族。他们不是贵族家族。他们通过羊毛、呢绒赚取了财富，但他们扮演主要角色的时间比美第奇更长。他们显然认为，不，我们想在这些
1420s, that the Medici's rivals are kind of sharpening their knives a bit. They're sick of the Medici, they're anxious about them, and they're ready to choose their moment to strike. And chief among them are this rival family that I mentioned before who are called the Albihtsi. The Albihtsi are also a mercantile family. They're not a noble family. They've made their money from wool, from cloth, but they have been major players for longer than the Medici. They clearly think, no, we want to get rid of these
竞争对手变得太强大之前除掉他们。他们连自己的家具都没买。完全正确，完全正确。阿尔比齐家族继承了他们的家具，而美第奇则在向艺术家们订制花哨的家具。他们的领袖是一个名叫雷纳尔多·迪阿尔比齐（Reynaldo Di Albici）的家伙，他是一个饱经风霜的——他大概会是肖恩·宾（Sean Bean）来演吧。哦，那这预示着他的命运不太妙啊。不，完全正确。他饱经风霜，曾是一名士兵，他非常高傲，非常骄傲，他说，你知道，美第奇绝对是一群渣滓，我无法忍受美第奇。他在1426年向他的支持者发表了一场精彩的演讲，这被记录在其中一本编年史中。他说，我们出身名门，然而现在我们发现自己在政府中与来自马杰洛、来自山里的人为伴。那些曾经是我们家里的仆人的人，他们竟然对待
rivals before they become too big. They haven't bought their own furniture. Exactly, exactly. The Albihtsi have inherited their furniture and the Medici are commissioning kind of fancy furniture from artists. Their leader is a guy called Reynaldo Di Albici and he is a kind of grizzled, you know, he'd be Sean Bean probably. Oh well that doesn't promise well for his fate. No, exactly. He's kind of grizzled, he's a former soldier, he's very haughty, he's very proud, and he says, you know, Medici are an absolute scum, I can't stand the Medici. And he actually gives a brilliant speech in 1426 to his supporters, which is reported in one of the Chronicles. And he says, we are well-born, yet now we find ourselves companions in the government with men from the Mugello, from the hills. Those who were once our household servants, they treat
在竞争对手变得过于强大之前消灭他们。他们甚至没有买过自己的家具。没错，没错。阿尔比齐家族继承了他们的家具，而美第奇家族则向艺术家定制各种华丽的家具。他们的领袖是一个叫雷纳尔多·迪·阿尔比齐的人，他有点饱经风霜，你知道的，大概就像肖恩·宾那样。哦，那这可预示着他的命运不太妙。不，确实如此。他有点饱经风霜，曾是一名军人，非常傲慢，非常骄傲，他说，你知道的，美第奇家族简直就是群渣滓，我简直无法忍受美第奇家族。他在1426年向支持者发表了一场精彩的演讲，这在编年史中有记载。他说，我们出身名门，然而现在我们却发现自己与来自穆杰洛、来自山里的人一起在政府中共事。那些曾经是我们的家仆的人，他们对待
us as servants while they themselves behave like lords. Shocking. And he says to his supporters, let us make sure that men of the right background end up in government and that these upstarts return to their pitiful trades and focus on providing food for their family tables. And actually, Tom, that reminds me of how you talk about other podcasters. The tone of hatred and condescension. I don't know what you're talking about. So on that note, let's move to the cliffhanger. Months after Giovanni has died, there was a bit of a crisis.
把我们当仆人，而他们自己却行为举止像个老爷。太令人震惊了。他对支持者说，我们要确保出身正统的人进入政府，而这些暴发户回到他们可怜的行业中去，专注于为自己家庭的餐桌提供食物。说实话，汤姆，这让我想起你谈论其他播客时的口吻。那种充满仇恨和居高临下的语气。我不知道你在说什么。所以顺便说一句，让我们转到悬念部分。乔瓦尼死后几个月，出现了一点危机。
The Albizzi are very keen on a little war to bolster their prestige, Ronaldo in particular. And the war they want is against the neighboring city state of Lucca. Cosimo thinks this is a very bad idea. He says, listen, we can't win because Lucca is supported by Milan, which is a kind of regional superpower. And let's not get tangled up with the Milanese. But the vote goes against him.
阿尔比奇家族非常渴望打一场小战争来提升他们的威望，尤其是里纳尔多。他们想要的战争是针对邻近的城市国家卢卡。科西莫认为这绝对是个坏主意。他说，听着，我们不可能赢，因为卢卡得到了米兰的支持，米兰某种程度上算是一个地区超级大国。咱们可别跟米兰人纠缠不清。但投票结果却与他背道而驰。
The Arbitzi get their way. The war starts. Kelsa breeze. It goes really badly for Florence. Florence starts running out of money. So this is great news for Cosimo. He lends money to the Florentine government at 33% interest. So he's put up all this money, he's been proved right, and he's making loads of cash from
阿尔比奇家族如愿以偿。战争爆发了。凯尔萨布里兹。对佛罗伦萨来说进展极其不顺。佛罗伦萨的资金开始捉襟见肘。这对科西莫来说绝对是个好消息。他以百分之三十三的利息向佛罗伦萨政府贷款。所以他投入了所有这些资金，证明他是对的，而且他正从
the interest payments. The Albizzi are absolutely furious. This has gone very badly. And by 1433, Tom, I hate to say it, but storm clouds are gathering over the Tuscan hills. Over Florence. Over Florence, exactly. There's lots of murmurs on the streets.
利息支付中赚取大量的现金。阿尔比奇家族气急败坏。事情进展得非常糟糕。到了1433年，汤姆，我真不想这么说，但托斯卡纳群山上空正乌云密布。佛罗伦萨上空。正是佛罗伦萨上空。街头有许多窃窃私语。
There's clearly going to be a showdown between the Albizzi and the Medici. And the Albizzi are spreading rumors. Cosimo is planning to seize power, and he has to be stopped. One night, it is said, he comes home and he finds the doors of his palazzo smeared with blood so he knows that something is coming. At the end of May 1433 he starts basically sending money away. He lodges 8,000
阿尔比奇家族和美第奇家族之间显然将有一场对决。阿尔比奇家族正在散布谣言。科西莫正密谋夺权，必须阻止他。据说有一天晚上，他回到家，发现自己宫殿的大门上涂满了鲜血，于是他知道事情要来了。1433年5月底，他基本上开始将资金转移出去。他把8000
Florians with the Dominican monks at San Marco, a monastery that we'll be talking about a lot in this series. He sends the rest of his money to the Medici banks in Rome and Naples. And later that summer, he moves his family out of the city as well to their country estate in the Mugello. And he takes them there. But while he is away, Rinaldo di Albiotti has been fixing the coming Signoria elections. So the end of August, the elections take place and they're a huge blow for the Medici. Seven out of nine of the people who are elected are Albizzi loyalists and the standard bearer, the gonfalonieri, is a bloke whose debt Rinaldo has just paid off. So this is looking very bleak. On the 1st of September, this new council, the
弗罗林存放在圣马可的多米尼加修士那里，这是一个我们在本系列中会经常谈论的修道院。他把剩下的钱寄到了罗马和那不勒斯的美第奇银行。同年夏天晚些时候，他还把家人搬出了城市，搬到了穆杰罗的乡村庄园。他把他们带到了那里。但当他不在的时候，里纳尔多·迪·阿尔比奥蒂一直在操纵即将到来的领地政府选举。因此在8月底，选举举行了，这对美第奇家族是一个巨大的打击。当选的九人中有七人是阿尔比奇的忠实拥护者，而旗手，也就是正义旗手，是一个里纳尔多刚帮其还清债务的家伙。所以这看起来非常黯淡。9月1日，这个新的委员会，即
Signoria, take office. And the next day, a message arrives at Cosimo's country estate in the Mugello saying, you must return to the city. We need your help making some important decisions. And he thinks, oh no. Now he could flee, but if he flees, he will lose everything. He could be declared a traitor and his property, confiscated or something. So he thinks, no, I've got to face the music. And on the 7th of September, he comes into the city. He goes straight to the Signoria and he finds that the council session has already started. And the captain of the guard leads him in, he leads him up the stairs and they get up to the council chamber,
领地政府，开始就职。第二天，一封信送到了科西莫在穆杰罗的乡村庄园，上面写着：你必须返回城市。我们需要你帮忙做出一些重要决定。他心想，哦不。现在他可以逃跑，但如果他逃跑，他将失去一切。他可能会被宣布为叛徒，他的财产被没收什么的。所以他想，不，我必须勇敢面对。9月7日，他来到了城市。他径直走向领地政府，发现议会会议已经开始了。卫队队长引领着他，带他走上楼梯，他们来到议会大厅，
but the doors are firmly shut and the guard says, keep walking. And they go up, up, and the captain leads him past and he shows him into a small cell, and then the captain says, you are under arrest on good grounds, as will soon be very clear. And then he slams the door, Tom. He locks it shut. Oh, and on that incredible bombshell, I think we should take a break. I think we should. Can't stand the tension otherwise. Are you crushing your bills? Defeating your monthly payments.
但大门紧闭，卫警说，继续走。他们往上走，往上走，队长领着他走过，把他领进一个小牢房，然后队长说：你以充足的理由被捕了，很快就会真相大白的。接着他砰地关上了门，汤姆。他把它锁死了。噢，带着这个惊人的重磅消息，我想我们该休息一下了。我想是的。否则我真受不了这紧张的气氛。你在清还账单吗？战胜你的每月付款。
Sounds like you're at the top of your financial game. Rise to it with the BMO Eclipse Rise Visa Card. The credit card that rewards your good financial habits. What's better than a well-marbled ribeye sizzling on the barbecue? A well-marbled ribeye sizzling on the barbecue that was carefully selected by an Instacart shopper and delivered to your door. A well marbled ribeye you ordered without even leaving the kiddie pool. Whatever groceries your summer calls for, Instacart has you covered. Download the Instacart app and enjoy $0 delivery fees on your first three orders.
听起来你在财务上已经处于巅峰状态。用 BMO Eclipse Rise Visa 卡来更上一层楼吧。这款信用卡能奖励你良好的财务习惯。有什么比在烧烤架上滋滋作响、大理石纹理完美的肋眼牛排更好的呢？由 Instacart 采购员精心挑选并送到你门上的、在烧烤架上滋滋作响的大理石纹理肋眼牛排。甚至不用离开儿童戏水池就能下单的大理石纹理肋眼牛排。无论你的夏天需要采购什么杂货，Instacart 都能满足你。下载 Instacart 应用，前三笔订单即可享受 0 美元配送费。
Service fees, exclusions, and terms apply. Instacart, groceries that over-deliver. Hello, I'm Gordon Carrera, a national security journalist. And I'm David McCloskey, CIA analyst turned spy novelist. Together, we're the co-hosts of another Goal Hanger show called The Rest is Classified, where we bring you the best stories from the world of secrets and spies. We have just released a series on the decades-long battle between the CIA and Osama Bin Laden,
服务费、排除项和条款适用。Instacart，超值配送的杂货。大家好，我是戈登·卡雷拉，一名国家安全记者。我是大卫·麦克洛斯基，曾任中情局分析师，现为间谍小说家。我们共同主持另一个火爆档节目《机密档案》，在这里我们将为你带来来自秘密与间谍世界的最佳故事。我们刚刚发布了一个系列，讲述了中情局与本·拉登之间长达数十年的斗争，
and this week we are stepping into the devastation of the 9-11 terror attacks to understand how Osama Bin Laden was able to carry out such a plot right under the nose of the CIA. It was a moment that changed global politics forever, shifting the focus of spy agencies away from nation states towards hunting for terrorists and understanding the extremist ideology that drove them. We will then go into the decade-long manhunt for Asal bin Laden, which culminated in a dramatic raid at his compound in Pakistan in 2011, which killed the world's most wanted terrorist. So if all of this sounds good, we've got a clip waiting for you at the end of the episode.
而本周，我们将重温 9·11 恐怖袭击带来的满目疮痍，以了解本·拉登如何在眼皮底下成功实施这样一场阴谋。这是一个永远改变全球政治的时刻，它将间谍机构的焦点从民族国家转移到了搜寻恐怖主义以及理解驱动他们的极端主义意识形态上。随后，我们将深入探讨长达十年的搜捕本·拉登行动，该行动最终在 2011 年对其巴基斯坦宅邸进行了戏剧性的突袭，击毙了世界上最头号的恐怖分子。所以，如果这一切听起来不错，我们在剧集结尾为你准备了一段精彩片段。
Hello everyone, welcome back to the rest is history. And Dominic, you left us on an absolute cliffhanger. Cosimo de' Medici loves his Tacitus, loves a high interest rate, loves a Circassian slave girl. He's gone to the Palazzo della Signoria and there, shock horror, he's been locked up in a cell. So what's going on? How's he going to get out of this? Well, two days go by, Tom, and he's sitting there in his cell.
大家好，欢迎回到《历史的剩余部分》。多米尼克，你给我们留下了巨大的悬念。科西莫·德·美第奇热爱他的塔西陀，热爱高利率，热爱切尔卡西亚女奴。他去了领地宫，在那里，天哪，他被关进了一个牢房。那么到底怎么回事？他要怎么逃出去呢？嗯，两天过去了，汤姆，他正坐在牢房里。
And then on the morning of the 9th of September, he hears the great bell, the vacca, tolling overhead. Surely mooing overhead. Mooing, I believe is the word, yeah. And this is summoning the citizens of Florence to this emergency mass meeting, a parlamento that I talked about in the first half. But as the people sort of flood towards the square, there are armed albizzi loyalists guarding the entrances. They turn away anybody who's suspected of being a Medici supporter. So this crowd assembles and the councillors ask approval. They say,
然后，在 9 月 9 日的早晨，他听到头顶上那口巨大的大钟——瓦卡钟在敲响。确切地说是头顶上在哞哞叫。哞哞叫，我相信就是这个词，是的。这正在召集佛罗伦萨市民参加我在前半部分提到的那场紧急群众大会，即议会大会。但当人们如潮水般涌向广场时，全副武装的阿尔比奇忠诚分子把守着入口。他们把任何被怀疑是美第奇支持者的人都赶走了。于是人群聚集起来，议员们请求批准。他们说，
can we have an emergency committee, a baliyah, to reform the city for the good of the people? So in other words, what they're carrying out is an anti-Medici coup. And this baliyah formally charges Cosimo with high treason. They say, ironically, given that he'd been against the war, they say, you've been prolonging the war with lucker to charge high interest rates and to line your own pockets. And is that accurate? Well, you know what? They had loads of witnesses, the witnesses had been tortured on the rack, so the witnesses were slightly unreliable. That said, I think a lot of modern historians say he probably had been prolonging the war to charge high interest.
我们能成立一个紧急委员会，一个巴利亚，来为了人民的利益整顿城市吗？换句话说，他们正在进行的是一场反美第奇政变。这个巴利亚正式指控科西莫犯有叛国罪。他们讽刺地说，鉴于他一直反对这场战争，他们说，你一直在延长与卢卡的战争，以收取高额利息并中饱私囊。这准确吗？嗯，你知道吗？他们有大量的证人，这些证人都在严刑拷打下受过审，所以这些证人们多少有些不可靠。不过话虽如此，我认为许多现代历史学家说，他可能确实一直在延长战争以收取高利率。
So yeah, I mean, it's, you know, listeners can make up their own minds. Ronaldo D'Arbitzi says, right, let's have the death penalty on this bloke. But actually, he now starts to find things very difficult. First of all, the Medici bank has so many kind of tentacles, as it were, everywhere, that foreign opinion is very much, you know, on the Medici side. So the Venetians, for example, send envoys and say, can we have a cross of my release, please. The standard bearer, who is meant to be an al-Bitsi loyalist, he actually takes a bribe from the Medici and says,
所以，是的，我的意思是，你知道的，听众可以自己做出判断。里纳尔多·迪·阿尔比奇说，好，让我们判这家伙死刑。但实际上，他现在发现事情变得非常棘手。首先，美第奇银行有着无数触角，可以说是无处不在，因此外国舆论在很大程度上，你知道的，是站在美第奇这边的。例如，威尼斯人派遣特使说，能释放我的十字架吗？本应是阿尔比奇忠实拥护者的正义旗手，实际上收受了美第奇的贿赂，说道，
oh, I'm actually very ill, I can't take part in the decision at all. He seems magnificently corrupt. Yeah, he's incredibly corrupt. Taking bungs from everybody, left, right and center. And also the al-Bizis are not sufficiently ruthless. They haven't arrested the other members of the Medici family. So Cosimo's cousin, Averardo, his brother, Lorenzo, other kind of Medici bigwigs are
哦，其实我病得很重，根本无法参与这个决定。他看起来真是腐败得惊人。是的，他极其腐败。左右逢源，四处收钱。而且阿尔比奇家族也不够冷酷无情。他们没有逮捕美第奇家族的其他成员。所以科西莫的堂兄阿韦拉尔多、他的弟弟洛伦佐以及美第奇的其他大人物们
kind of supposed to be raising mercenaries outside the city. And so people are very anxious about that. So that definitely loses him points on the Sandbrook scale of effective political operators then. He's a bodger. He's made a mess of this. He had his chance and he's blown it. Because basically when the Ballia hands down its verdict, Cosimo is not executed.
据说是要在城外招募雇佣兵。因此人们对此感到非常焦虑。所以在桑德布鲁克的高效政治操盘手量表上，这绝对给他扣分了。他是个笨拙的家伙。他把事情搞砸了。他曾有机会却给搞砸了。因为基本上当巴利亚宣布判决时，科西莫并没有被处决。
He's banished to Padua for 10 years. And Cosimo is brought in to hear the sentence. He gives this incredibly disingenuous speech in which he says, you know, I'm very happy to be exiled because I know it's for the good of Florence. I leave my heart and soul with you, he says, my troubles will be easy to bear as I know that my adversity will bring peace and happiness to the city. Well, you know who he's echoing there is Cicero, who was the great model for Italian humanists who was exiled by his rival and then makes a triumphant return.
他被流放到帕多瓦 10 年。科西莫被带进来听取判决。他发表了一篇极其虚伪的演讲，在演讲中他说，你知道，我非常高兴被流放，因为我知道这是为了佛罗伦萨的利益。他说，我把我的心和灵魂留给你们，我的痛苦将很容易承受，因为我知道我的逆境将给这座城市带来和平与幸福。嗯，你知道他在呼应谁吗？是西塞罗，他是意大利人文主义者的伟大楷模，曾被他的对手流放，随后又凯旋归来。
And I imagine that with that speech, Cosimo is channeling Cicero and everybody knows he's channeling Cicero. So by saying that, he's basically saying, I will be back. Yeah. And remember he had Cicero in his library. So he's very familiar with all this kind of stuff. But I think his listeners would be familiar as well, just because Cicero is such a massive figure in the imagination of the time. They've all had this kind of humanist education, so they're all
我猜科西莫在发表那番演讲时，他正在模仿西塞罗，而每个人都知道他在模仿西塞罗。所以通过这样说，他基本上是在说，我会回来的。是的。记住，他的藏书里有西塞罗的书。所以他对所有这类事情都非常熟悉。但我认为他的听众也会很熟悉，仅仅是因为西塞罗在那个时代的想象中是一个如此庞大的巨人。他们都接受过这种人文主义教育，所以他们都
really into this stuff. Off he goes into exile, and it's like a triumphant progress. He's greeted an honoured guest wherever he goes. He doesn't actually go to Padua, he goes to Venice, and he's treated as a VIP, and he's put up in the monastery of San Giorgio Maggiore. You know, he lives like a prince, it's all great. So, Ronaldo must be thrilled about this. He's raging. He's back in Florence and he says to all his sort of supporters, look, we have made a terrible mess of this. We've got the worst of all worlds. We've struck at the Medici family, but we haven't finished them off.
对这些东西非常着迷。他踏上了流亡之路，这就像是一次凯旋的巡游。无论他走到哪里，他都受到贵宾般的迎接和尊崇。他实际上并没有去帕多瓦，而是去了威尼斯，被当作贵宾对待，并被安置在圣乔治马焦雷修道院。你知道的，他过着王子般的生活，一切都好极了。所以，里纳尔多对此一定欣喜若狂。他怒火中烧。他回到佛罗伦萨，对他的所有支持者说，听着，我们把事情搞得一团糟。我们得到了最糟糕的结果。我们打击了美第奇家族，却没有彻底消灭他们。
Scotched the snake, not killed it. Exactly. And actually, they continue to do this. So over the winter, you know, they should have rolled up the Medici network. They should have won over Medici clients in Venice and Rome. You know, they should have done all this. They should have started killing people, but they didn't. That's so sound broke. They should have started killing people.
斩草不除根，春风吹又生。正是如此。而且实际上，他们一直在这样做。所以整个冬天，你知道的，他们本该瓦解美第奇的网络。他们本该赢得威尼斯和罗马的美第奇客户。你知道的，他们本该做所有这些。他们本该开始杀人，但他们没有。这太符合桑德布鲁克的风格了。他们本该开始杀人。
Well, they absolutely should. Listen, if you're not going to do it properly, don't play the game at all. That's my verdict. Yeah, yeah, I'm hearing you. So anyway, momentum kind of leeches away from the Albihtsi. And in the late summer of 1434, there's a Medici majority in the Signore elections. Ronaldo says, okay, now is the time for an armed coup. Enough of this messing around.
嗯，他们绝对应该。听着，如果你不打算彻底解决，那就别玩这个游戏。这就是我的结论。对，对，我听懂你的意思了。所以无论如何，阿尔比奇家族的势头逐渐流失。1434 年夏末，在领地选举中，美第奇派占据了多数。里纳尔多说，好吧，现在是发动武装政变的时候了。别再瞎折腾了。
But again, the Al-Bizy allies are like, no, I don't like the thought of an armed coup. We don't like that kind of thing. And eventually the Signoria, they summon back Cosmo and they summon, they say to Ronaldo, and literally is the story of the previous year reversed. And they say to Ronaldo, come and meet us at the palace for an urgent, important meeting. Ronaldo realizes, okay, they're going to throw me into prison. So actually, he doesn't repeat Cosimo's mistake. He goes back to his house. He says to his guards, secure the city.
但阿尔比奇的盟友们又是一副不情愿的样子，不，我可不想搞什么武装政变。我们不喜欢那种事。最终领地政府召回了科西莫，他们把里纳尔多叫来，对里纳尔多说，这简直是去年历史的重演。他们对里纳尔多说，来宫殿跟我们开个紧急重要会议吧。里纳尔多意识到，好吧，他们要把我投进监狱了。所以实际上，他没有重复科西莫的错误。他回到了自己的家。他对警卫说，守卫这座城市。
Go out into the city. And he calls in loads of mercenaries from outside Florence. But over the next few days, his support melts away. It's pretty obvious that the pro-Medici council, the signoria have made preparations of their own. They've got troops of their own. Now, as it happens, the bloke who sorts all this out is the pope because he's also in Florence.
去城里。并且他从佛罗伦萨城外召集了大量的雇佣兵。但在接下来的几天里，他的支持者却烟消云散了。很明显，亲美第奇的议会，即领地政府，已经做好了他们自己的准备。他们有自己的军队。现在，碰巧的是，解决这一切的人是教皇，因为他也在佛罗伦萨。
Wow. That's a turn up for the books. So he's Eugenius IV and he's been kicked out of Rome by a mob and he's basically lodging in a monastery in Santa Maria Novella in the center of Florence. And he needs money to get back to Rome. Who are you going to ask? Yeah, you're going to ask the Medici bank.
哇。这真是个意想不到的转折。所以他是尤金四世，他被暴民赶出了罗马，基本上暂住在佛罗伦萨市中心的圣母玛利亚诺韦拉修道院里。他需要钱回罗马。你打算向谁开口？对，你得去问美第奇银行。
He says, look, I'll act as a mediator on this. He says to Ronaldo, I don't think you can win. I think you should surrender and I will try to persuade the Medici to be lenient with you. So, by the end of September, the struggle is over. The Signoria recall Cosimo to Florence. He makes this great progress through the countryside. There are crowds along the roads.
他说，听着，我来当这个调解人。他对里纳尔多说，我认为你赢不了。我认为你应该投降，我会试着说服美第奇对你宽大处理。因此，到了 9 月底，这场争斗结束了。领地政府将科西莫召回佛罗伦萨。他在乡间凯旋而归。道路两旁挤满了人群。
Then on the 6th of October, he enters Florence in triumph. Even bigger crowds greet him as a hero, chanting his name and stuff. However, I will say, there are two sides to this story. The city has been secured beforehand by hundreds of Medici soldiers. So the crowds are not exactly under duress, but there is a degree of intimidation. Basically if you're not a Medici supporter, you keep very quiet during this period. So you could argue it's a genuine upsurge of kind of popular affection, or you could say this is an intimidated population
接着在 10 月 6 日，他凯旋进入佛罗伦萨。更多的人群将他迎为英雄，高呼他的名字等等。不过，我要说的是，这个故事有两个方面。这座城市事先已经被数百名美第奇士兵控制了。所以人群并非完全处于胁迫之下，但确实存在一定程度的威吓。基本上，如果你不是美第奇的支持者，在这段时期你就会保持绝对的沉默。所以你可以争辩说，这是民众真挚爱戴的热潮，或者你也可以说，在基本上经历了一场军事政变之后，这是一个受到惊吓的群体。
after what's basically a military coup. And Cosimo, see this is why I like Cosimo, he's a serious person, Tom. He does what has to be done. He doesn't kill a lot of people, but he is ruthless. He just says, right, now we have to dismantle the Al Bizzi network completely. We kick them out of Florence forever. So the whole clan are banished from Florence. And does that last? Does that stick? Yeah, it works.
而科西莫，瞧，这就是我喜欢科西莫的原因，他是个办实事的人，汤姆。他该出手时就出手。他没有大开杀戒，但他冷酷无情。他直截了当的说，好，现在我们必须彻底拆除阿尔比奇的网络。我们要把他们永远驱逐出佛罗伦萨。于是整个宗族都被驱逐出佛罗伦萨。这管用吗？能维持长久吗？是的，管用。
So he's then elected, gone Falonieri, standard bearer of the Signoria. He only does it for two months, but it's just a little symbol. You know, I am the top man. I'm the top dog now. So actually he's now moved from being Cicero to Caesar Augustus. Yes. And actually this is a very, this is a comparison that was on my mind the whole time. Basically Cosimo is going to control Florence now for the next 30 years.
所以他随后当选为正义旗手，即领地政府的旗手。他只任职了两个月，但这只是一个小小的象征。你知道的，我才是最高领袖。我现在是头号人物了。所以实际上他现在从西塞罗转变成了凯撒奥古斯都。是的。事实上，这是一个我自始至终都在脑海里盘算的比较。基本上，科西莫将在未来 30 年里掌控佛罗伦萨。
And I would say he is one of the most impressive politicians that we've had on this, on this podcast and we've done however many hundred episodes, but he really stands out for me. And the Augustus comparison is exactly the one that was on my mind. So like Augustus, he keeps the existing system, the Republican system. The difference is that now when you pull a name out of the leather bag, it is certain to have been pre-approved, to have been chosen by Cosimo and his allies. Now, there's always, as you said, there has been always been bribery, there's always been patronage and whatnot, but they are doing it in a really systematic, ruthless way. Now, if you step out of line, you won't be killed, but you might find yourself
而且我要说，他是我们在这个播客里见过的最令人印象深刻的政治家之一，我们虽然做过几百期节目，但他真的让我印象深刻。而奥古斯都的对比恰好就是我一直在想的。所以就像奥古斯都一样，他保留了现有的体制，也就是共和体制。不同之处在于，现在当你从皮袋子里抽出一个名字时，那个人绝对是事先经过批准的，是由科西莫和他的盟友们挑选的。现在，正如你所说，一直存在着贿赂，一直存在着裙带关系等等，但他们现在是以一种非常系统化、冷酷无情的方式在做这件事。如果你越界了，你不会被杀，但你可能会发现自己
with an unexpectedly large tax bill, or you won't get planning permission for your new palazzo, or whatever, or at worst you'll be banished and your property confiscated. Foreigners always describe Cosimo as the lord of the city, as the master of the city, but he doesn't often hold public office, in fact he very rarely holds it again. It's his clients and surrogates who hold public office, and he's kind of in the shadows the whole time. And your Augustus comparison, Donald Weinstein on his book on this period says, Cosimo liked to be seen as a benevolent father figure who embodied the traditional Florentine virtues of the pious Christian, the shrewd pragmatic merchant and the republic loving patriot. In other words, he's a kindly father figure,
收到了一张数额大得惊人的税单，或者你的新宫殿拿不到规划许可，诸如此类，或者最糟糕的是你会被流放，财产被没收。外国人总是把科西莫描述为城市的领主，城市的掌控者，但他并不经常担任公职，事实上他极少再次担任公职。是他的门客和代理人担任公职，而他自始至终都处于幕后。正如唐纳德·温斯坦在他关于这一时期的书中所说，你与奥古斯都的对比，科西莫喜欢被视为一个仁慈的父亲形象，他体现了虔诚的基督徒、精明务实的商人和热爱共和国的爱国者等传统的佛罗伦萨美德。换句话说，他是一个慈祥的父亲形象，
he's the first citizen, he's not a prince, he's not a king or an emperor or anything like that, but he's just Primus Inter pares. So, and I'm sure the Augustus comparison would have played on his mind, and he's basically copying from the playbook. Yeah, of course. I'm sure he's not kind of doing it in antiquarian way.
他是第一公民，他不是王子，不是国王或皇帝之类的人物，他只是同辈中的第一人。所以，我相信奥古斯都的对比一定在他的脑海中浮现过，他基本上是在照搬这本政治秘籍。是的，当然。我确信他不是以一种古董般的方式在做这件事。
I mean, it clearly gels with his character, but he must be thinking all the time, well, you know, I have precedent here. Exactly. Now there are sometimes protests. There's one incident in particular in 1458. There's a lot of protests about election rigging and just how much money Cosimo is making from lending money to the government. And, you know And he does what needs to be done. He cuts it off before it can gather momentum. He actually says, people are protesting about election rigging. Well, fine, I'll double down. And he calls a big parliamento. He calls in loads of troops from Milan to police the streets. And so when people assemble to decide on what they want to do with it, they want to change the constitution, the place is lined with his armed men.
我的意思是，这显然符合他的性格，但他肯定无时无刻不在想，嗯，你知道的，我这里有先例。没错。有时候确实会有抗议。特别是1458年发生了一起事件。有很多关于操纵选举以及科西莫通过向政府发放贷款赚了多少钱的抗议，你知道的，
He gets his way. He gets given full legal control of the electoral process and he will never ever be challenged again. So again, he's just done what needs to be done and got his way. And I mentioned he's brought in lots of troops. He brought in troops from Milan. Why Milan? And this brings us to his other big success story, which is his foreign policy. So his father Giovanni had bet on that bloke who became, if only temporarily, Pope and slept with 200 women in seven years. And that had really worked out. And Cosimo
他做他该做的事。他在抗议形成气候之前将其掐断。他实际上说，人们在抗议操纵选举。好吧，很好，我将变本加厉。他召集了一次大型议会大会。他从米兰调来大批军队来维持街道治安。因此，当人们聚集在一起决定他们想对它做什么时，他们想要修改宪法，那个地方站满了他的武装人员。他如愿以偿。他获得了对选举过程的全面合法控制权，并且再也不会受到任何挑战。所以再次说明，他只是做了需要做的事并如愿以偿。我提到他调来了很多军队。他从米兰调来了军队。为什么是米兰？这就把我们带到了他的另一个巨大成功故事，那就是他的外层政策。所以他的父亲乔瓦尼曾押注于那个成为教皇（尽管只是暂时的）并在七年里与两百个女人睡觉的家伙。而这确实取得了成效。而科西莫
places a similar bet in a big Milanese succession crisis. So Milan is eclipsed by Florence, I think, in the popular imagination now, sort of 14th, 15th century. But Milan was a massive power broker in the Italian landscape. It's rivaled really only by Venice.
在一次重大的米兰继承危机中下了类似的赌注。所以我想在公众想象中，现在在14、15世纪，米兰已经被佛罗伦萨黯然失色了。但米兰一直是意大利版图上一个庞大的权力掮客。能与之抗衡的实际上只有威尼斯。
And Milan had always been one of Florence's rivals, but Cosimo wants to have a little diplomatic revolution, an ally with Milan. So for 200 years Milan had been ruled by the Visconti family. And the current Duke of Milan is a man called Filippo Maria Visconti, and he is a tremendous character. I'm gonna read you what Christopher Hibbert
米兰一直是佛罗伦萨的对手之一，但科西莫想要来一场外交大革命，与米兰结盟。因此，米兰两百年来一直由维斯孔蒂家族统治。现任米兰公爵是一个名叫菲利波·玛丽亚·维斯孔蒂的人，他是一个了不起的人物。我要读给你听克里斯托弗·希伯特
writes about him. He'd been known on summer days to restrict the rich clothes from his grotesquely fat and dirty body and roll about naked in his garden. He was so ugly, he refused to have his portrait painted. So nervous, he screamed at the sight of a naked sword. So frightened of thunder that he had a soundproof room built in his palace." And my favorite thing is we love a prankster and a practical joker. We do, yeah.
是如何描写他的。据说在夏日里，他会脱下罩在他那畸形肥胖又肮脏身体上的华贵衣服，在花园里赤身裸体地打滚。他长得太丑了，以至于拒绝让人画肖像。他神经质到看到出鞘的剑就会尖叫。他害怕打雷，以至于在宫殿里让人建了一个隔音室。”而我最喜欢的是，我们都喜欢恶作剧者和实用玩笑制造者。我们是的，没错。
So he would often talk to a courier and then unexpectedly he would produce a snake out of his sleeve, which I think would be terrifying. Presumably he's doing that because the serpent is the emblem of the Visconti, isn't it? It's on its kind of coat of arms, the great viper. Yeah, but what a great trick to have a viper stuffed in your clothing to pull them out at the moment's notice. The one downside with this guy, Filippo Maria Visconti, he's not a great husband. So he had two wives, one of them he just had her executed, and the second one, on their wedding night, he heard a dog howling in the background.
所以他经常跟信使说话，然后出其不意地从袖子里掏出一条蛇，我觉得这会吓死人。大概他这么做是因为蛇是维斯孔蒂家族的标志，对吧？它在家族纹章上，那条巨大的毒蛇。是的，不过能在衣服里藏一条毒蛇，随时随地都能掏出来，这真是个绝妙的把戏。这家伙唯一的缺点，菲利波·玛丽亚·维斯孔蒂，他不是个好丈夫。所以他有过两个妻子，其中一个被他下令处决了，第二个妻子在新婚之夜，他听到背景里有狗在叫。
He said, oh my God, that's a terrible sign. This woman's obviously dreadful. Get rid. And he immediately had her locked up. Not many children then. So no legitimate heir. Now he has an illegitimate daughter and she marries a bloke, another great character actually, who count Francesco Sforza. This bloke Sforza, his father had been an illiterate peasant who founded his own mercenary company, one of the best companies
他说，哦天哪，这是个可怕的征兆。这个女人显然太可怕了。除掉她。他立刻把她关了起来。那这么说没几个孩子了。所以没有合法继承人。现在他有一个私生女，她嫁给了一个家伙，实际上也是个了不起的人物，弗朗切斯科·斯福尔扎伯爵。这个叫斯福尔扎的家伙，他的父亲曾是一个目不识丁的农民，创立了自己的雇佣兵连，是意大利最好的佣兵连之一。
in Italy. Sforza inherited it and he is regarded as the absolute, if you like mercenary captains, he's number one. He can bend metal bars with his bare hands, Tom, like Augustus the Strong. But he doesn't throw foxes in the air. He doesn't throw foxes in the air. No, he's got better things to do. He wants to win the government of Milan. So there's an immensely complicated Milanese succession crisis and Cosimo decides, this
斯福尔扎继承了它，他被视为雇佣兵首领中的绝对翘楚，他是第一名。他能用双手把铁棒弯曲，汤姆，就像大力士奥古斯都一样。但他不把狐狸扔到空中。他不把狐狸扔到空中。不，他有更重要的事情要做。他想赢得米兰的统治权。因此发生了一场极其复杂的米兰继承危机，科西莫决定，
bloke, Schwarzer, bar-bending, mercenary captain, he is the man. He lends him loads of money, he gives him an unprecedented overdraft facility, 3,000 ducats, and armed with this amazing overdraft facility, he ends up getting control of Milan. So now there is a formal alliance between Cosimo's Florence and Sforza's Milan. And this means that basically the Medici are, they're not exactly invulnerable, but if anybody attacks them, they can call on the most powerful city in Northern Italy. So Cosimo has the cash and Sforza has the manpower. Yeah.
这家伙，斯福尔扎，这个能弯曲铁棒的雇佣兵首领，他就是对的人。他借给他一大笔钱，给他提供了前所未有的透支额度，三千达克特，带着这笔惊人的透支额度，他最终控制了米兰。所以现在科西莫的佛罗伦萨和斯福尔扎的米兰之间有了正式的同盟。这意味着美第奇家族基本上，虽然不能说是刀枪不入，但如果有人攻击他们，他们可以调动意大利北部最强大的城市。所以科西莫有现金，而斯福尔扎有人手。是的。
And as long as they're in cahoots, no one can really bring down either one of them. Exactly right. And the interesting thing actually is that a lesser man than Cosimo would have tried to take the opportunity to expand Florence's territory and to expand kind of Florence's empire, but he's really smart. He knows that Florence can't really support a larger empire. It's not a big enough city. So his priority is basically he wants peace because he just wants to make money.
只要他们沆瀣一气，就没人能真正打倒他们中的任何一个。完全正确。有趣的是，一个不如科西莫的人会试图抓住这个机会扩大佛罗伦萨的领土并扩张佛罗伦萨的帝国，但他非常聪明。他知道佛罗伦萨实际上无法支撑一个更大的帝国。它不够大。所以他的首要任务基本上是他想要和平，因为他只想赚钱。
He will use the Milanese troops to protect what we have. And in the meantime, I'll just lend people money at 33% interest and we'll become richer and richer. And of course create great masterpieces of Renaissance art. Exactly. But I think this point about money is actually really important because Cosmo is much less famous than his
他将利用米兰军队来保护我们所拥有的。与此同时，我只管以百分之三十三的利息借钱给别人，我们就会变得越来越富有。当然，还要创作文艺复兴艺术的伟大杰作。完全正确。但我认为关于金钱这一点其实非常重要，因为科西莫远没有他的
grandson Lorenzo the Magnificent. But Tom, I believe him to be the greater man because he never, he never loses sight of what matters, which is the balance sheet. He doesn't showboat, does he? He doesn't showboat. He doesn't.
孙子洛伦佐大帝那么出名。但汤姆，我相信他更伟大，因为他从未，从未忘记真正重要的是什么，那就是资产负债表。他从不哗众取宠，对吧？他不哗众取宠。他确实没有。
He's all about the bank. So he expands the bank across Europe. So there are representatives. I mean, the list of cities, London, Naples, Cologne, Geneva, Lyon, Basel, Avignon, Bruges, Antwerp, Newbeck, Ancona, Bologna, Rome, Pisa, Venice. There are Medici representatives, Medici branch offices everywhere. And they can source relics, silk manuscripts, choir boys, you name it, they can deliver it. And as a result, they are making enormous amounts of money. So I think one estimate, in 10 years after 1442,
他一心只想着银行。所以他在全欧洲扩展银行业务。所以有代表。我的意思是，城市的名单，伦敦、那不勒斯、科隆、日内瓦、里昂、巴塞尔、阿维尼翁、布鲁日、安特卫普、吕贝克、安科纳、博洛尼亚、罗马、比萨、威尼斯。美第奇的代表和美第奇的分支机构无处不在。他们可以采购圣物、丝绸手稿、唱诗班男孩，你要什么，他们就能送达。因此，他们赚取了巨额的财富。所以我想有一个估计，在 1442 年之后的 10 年里，
they make almost 190,000 Florins in profits. And this is probably an underestimate, because they're also fiddling books, because they don't want people to know how much money they are making. However, as you will know, there is a hidden cost to making all this money. And that is the future of his eternal soul. Yeah. It's that God hates you and you will burn in hell, which is unfortunate
他们的利润接近 19万 弗罗林。这可能还是个低估的数字，因为他们还在做假账，因为他们不想让别人知道他们赚了多少钱。然而，正如你所知，赚取所有这些钱背后有一个隐藏的代价。那就是他永恒灵魂的未来。是的。那就是上帝恨你，你会在地狱里燃烧，这真不幸，
because this is the great problem with banking is the Bible explicitly says if you charge interest, if you're guilty of usury, you're a very bad person indeed. So you might think how do they get away with it? I mean, there are various kind of fudges. It's often pretended that people will pretend that the interest is a gift. Oh, we're not really charging interest. It just so happens that the borrower has given us this lovely present at the end of the loan.
因为这是银行业的一大难题，圣经明确规定，如果你收取利息，如果你犯了高利贷罪，你确实是一个非常坏的人。所以你可能会想，他们是怎么逃脱惩罚的？我的意思是，有各种各样的敷衍了事。人们通常会假装利息是一份礼物。哦，我们其实没有收利息。这只是碰巧借款人在贷款结束时给了我们这份可爱的礼物。
I don't think God is going to accept that. But would God accept this? Could you disguise the interest payments as a travel ex-style commission fee on changing duckets into florins or whatever it might be? I think that's more plausible. Yeah, well, this is what they do with the paper accounts because they're using lots of different currencies. I don't think God would have anything against exchange rates. Well Cosimo was worried that he might because Cosimo was a serious person Tom and he is undoubtedly familiar with something like Dante's
我不认为上帝会接受那个。但上帝会接受这个吗？你能把利息支付伪装成将达克特兑换成弗罗林之类的差旅费佣金吗？我觉得那个更合理。好吧，这就是他们在纸面账目上所做的，因为他们使用许多不同的货币。我不认为上帝会对汇率有任何意见。好吧，科西莫担心他可能会有意见，因为科西莫是个严肃的人，汤姆，他无疑对诸如但丁的
Divine Comedy. When Dante goes to hell, or the poet in the story, he meets usurers, kind of bankers, and they're weighed down by these bags of gold around their necks and they're trapped in kind of burning, scorching sand. No one wants that to happen to them. No, not for eternity. No. I mean, not even for a few seconds, really. I wouldn't want that for any period of time.
《神曲》之类的内容非常熟悉。当但丁下地狱时，或者说故事里的那个诗人，他遇到了高利贷者，也就是某种银行家，他们脖子上挂着沉甸甸的金袋子，被困在燃烧滚烫的沙子里。没人希望这种事发生在自己身上。不，绝不希望永世如此。不，甚至连几秒钟都不行，真的。我绝不希望任何一段时间是那样的。
So how do you deal with that? How do you cope? Well, here is an example. Again, something that will very much appeal to you, Tom. In 1439, Cosimo plays a key part in hosting in Florence an ecumenical council of the Western and Eastern churches. Oh yes, an ecumenical council. Yes, get in. There are people sobbing with joy listening to this podcast, you know, basically all over your own household.
那你怎么处理呢？你怎么应对？好吧，这里有一个例子。同样，这也是一件会非常吸引你的事，汤姆。1439 年，科西莫在佛罗伦萨主办西方与东方教会的大公会议中扮演了关键角色。哦，是的，大公会议。耶，加入吧。你知道，听这个播客的人们正感动得痛哭流涕，基本上传遍了你自己的整个家庭。
No, not even my own household. Oh, really? Just you? Just me. So Cosimo personally welcomes Pope Eugenius IV, the bloke who negotiated that deal, the patriarch of Constantinople pitches up in Florence, and the emperor of the East, the emperor in Constantinople, John Palaeologus. And actually the result of this council is that it was a very short-lived and
不，甚至连我自己的家庭都没有。哦，真的吗？只有你？只有我自己。所以科西莫亲自迎接了尤金四世教皇，也就是那个谈判达成那项协议的家伙，君士坦丁堡牧首来到了佛罗伦萨，还有东方的皇帝，君士坦丁堡的皇帝约翰·帕莱奥洛格斯。实际上这次会议的结果是，它是一个非常短暂且
abortive deal, a union between the churches of this council is that it's a very short-lived and abortive deal, a union between the churches of Rome and Constantinople, between Catholicism and Orthodoxy. The reason for that being that the Turks are closing in on Constantinople and the emperor is desperate for Latin help. Yeah, exactly. For Cosimo, all this is absolutely brilliant. Because basically, to put this up, it's like hosting the World Cup
流产的协议，这次会议的教会联合是一个非常短暂且流产的协议，罗马和君士坦丁堡教会之间的联合，天主教和东正教之间的联合。原因在于土耳其人正在逼近君士坦丁堡，而皇帝极度渴望拉丁人的帮助。是的， exatamente。对科西莫来说，这一切绝对太棒了。因为基本上，要举办这个，就像举办世界杯
or the Eurovision Song Contest or something. Florence can't really afford it. So basically, he has to lend the city, his own city, loads of money, and he takes home 14,000 forins in interest. It's worked out splendidly for him. So I think this is a perfect example of the fusion of politics, finance, of religious faith and culture that powers the Renaissance, the Italian Renaissance. So first of all, all of these scholars from Constantinople, they have turned up with loads
或者欧洲电视网歌唱大赛之类的。佛罗伦萨其实负担不起。所以基本上，他不得不向这座城市，他自己的城市，借一大笔钱，然后他带回了 14000 弗罗林的利息。这对他的运作简直妙不可言。所以我认为这是政治、金融、宗教信仰和文化融合的完美例证，正是这些推动了文艺复兴，意大利文艺复兴。首先，所有这些来自君士坦丁堡的学者们，他们带着大量的
of Greek manuscripts that they're going to quote from in these debates. So their bags are kind of bulging with manuscript rolls or whatever. This is when Plato really gets reintroduced. It's Plethon, this guy who actually he doesn't even approve of Christianity. He wants to go back to worshipping the ancient gods. And he brings Plato in Greek and he sets up a school there. And this is where Plato really becomes part of the bloodstream of the Renaissance. People become very excited about Plato in Florence.
希腊手稿出现在这里，他们将在这些辩论中引用这些手稿。所以他们的包里塞满了手稿卷轴之类的东西。这就是柏拉图真正重新被引入的时候。正是普莱通这个人，他甚至不赞同基督教。他想回到崇拜古代神的时代。他用希腊语带来了柏拉图并在那里建立了一所学校。这就是柏拉图真正成为文艺复兴血液一部分的地方。人们在佛罗伦萨对柏拉图感到非常兴奋。
They're like, oh, wow, this is amazing, all this stuff. And actually some of these manuscripts end up in Cosimo's library. I think he probably they're given as presents or he buys them or who knows, but they basically end up there. So he's got all the manuscripts. We know he loves all these books. We know he's into all this stuff, but also the money that he's taken home in profits, he uses that money to launder his immortal soul. So he commissions as a result of this council a new fresco in the sacristy of the Basilica of San Lorenzo, the church where the Medici are buried. And you can see it today, you know, it's one of the many tourist attractions
他们会想，哦，哇，这太棒了，所有这些东西。事实上，其中一些手稿最终落入了科西莫的图书馆。我想他可能是别人作为礼物送给他的，或者他买的，或者谁知道呢，但它们基本上就留在了那里。所以他拥有了所有的手稿。我们知道他热爱所有这些书。我们知道他热衷于所有这些东西，而且他带回家的巨额利润，他用这些钱来洗白他那不朽的灵魂。因此，作为这次会议的结果，他委托在圣洛伦索大殿（美第奇家族埋葬的教堂）的圣器室里绘制了一幅新的湿壁画。你今天还能看到它，你知道的，它是与科西莫及其家族相关的众多旅游景点之一。
that are associated with Cosimo and his family. And this is textbook Italian Renaissance patron behavior, because the church is telling them all the time, listen, you're making a lot of money in interest payments and in usury, but it's actually fine. Because if you spend a lot of that on charitable works on arms, or even better, if you invest it in monasteries and church buildings, then God will probably forgive you and it'll all be alright. Do you think God likes art? I think God loves this because obviously the church know exactly what God wants, don't they? I can't believe you would question that, Tom. They have a hotline to God and the Pope in particularly, he knows exactly what God wants
这就是教科书式的意大利文艺复兴赞助人行为，因为教会一直在告诉他们，听着，你在利息支付和高利贷中赚了很多钱，但其实没关系。因为如果你把其中的很大一部分花在慈善事业上，或者更好的是，如果你把它投资在修道院和教堂建筑上，那么上帝很可能会原谅你，一切都会好起来的。你觉得上帝喜欢艺术吗？我想上帝一定会喜欢这个，因为很显然教会完全知道上帝想要什么，不是吗？我真不敢相信你会有这种疑问，汤姆。他们有通往上帝的热线，特别是教皇，他确切地知道上帝想要什么
and he knows that God wants a lovely fresco or a nice statue or something of that ilk. Yeah, of course. So Cosimo's father Giovanni, he had hired Brunelleschi, the dome of the cathedral man, to redo the Medici Church of San Lorenzo. Cosimo himself spends more money on San Lorenzo. He spends money on the baptistry of the cathedral. If you go to Florence and you go do a sort of three day itinerary, a lot of the churches you will visit are San Michele, Santa Croce, Santa Maria delle Angelie, like all the classic tourist sites, these are places that Cosimo has spent money on.
并且他知道上帝想要一张精美的壁画或一尊精美的雕像之类的好东西。是的，当然。所以科西莫的父亲乔瓦尼曾聘请大教堂穹顶的设计者伯鲁内莱斯基来重修美第奇教堂圣洛伦索。科西莫本人在圣洛伦索上花费了更多的钱。他在大教堂的洗礼堂上花钱。如果你去佛罗伦萨，做一个三天的行程，你将参观的许多教堂都是圣米凯莱、圣十字、圣母天使报喜堂，就像所有这些经典的旅游景点一样，这些都是科西莫花过钱的地方。
And the one of the place above all, which will play a big part in this series, is the Dominican monastery at San Marco. And here at one point, Cosimo said to the Pope, you know, I'm actually genuinely quite worried about this burning sand. Like I'd love to get out of that somehow. And the Pope said, well, that monastery is the place, like really invest in that monastery. Cosimo spent 30,000 Florins completely renovating it. New church, new refectory for the monks, new library with hundreds of rare manuscripts. I mean, it's a very impossible question to answer, but in dollars, what would...
而最重要、在这个系列中将发挥重要作用的地方，是圣马可的多米尼加修道院。在这里，科西莫曾对教皇说，你知道，我其实真的有点担心那些燃烧的沙子。我很想某种程度上逃脱那个。教皇说，嗯，那座修道院就是那个地方，真的要在那座修道院上投资。科西莫花费了 30000 弗罗林对其进行了彻底翻新。新教堂，修道士们的新食堂，藏有数百份珍贵手稿的新图书馆。我的意思是，这是一个非常不可能回答的问题，但如果折算成美元，会……
Oh, in millions. No question would be, there'd be millions. I mean, just the, if you think about the equivalent cost today of renovating a building like that, that state of the art stuff, and then donating a library, you know, with the very most up to the minute expensive and rare resources. It's the equivalent of a big donor to an American university or something like that. It's that kind of, a super rich donor to an American university laundering their reputation. I mean, it's exactly what it is.
哦，以百万计。毫无疑问，那将是数以百万计的。我的意思是，仅仅是，如果你想想今天翻新这样一栋建筑的同等成本，那些最先进的东西，然后捐赠一个图书馆，你知道的，拥有最新、最昂贵、最罕见的资源。这相当于一个美国大学的大额捐赠者之类的人。就是那种超级富有的捐赠者向美国大学捐款来洗白他们的声誉。我的意思是，这完全就是那么回事。
So that's got to keep the burning sand at bay. Yeah, I think so. So actually rather like, you know, an American donor will have their name on the sort of the Tom Holland Library at the University of Arizona, right? Pope Eugenius IV gives Cosimo a bull of expiation, which is basically like a pardon for his sins. Cosimo has it put up above the door of the sacristy. So to remind everybody, you know, I've paid for this, and as a result, I'm free of sin. Brilliant.
所以这必定能挡住炽热的沙子。对，我也这么觉得。这其实有点像，你知道的，美国捐赠者会把自己的名字留在亚利桑那大学的汤姆·霍兰图书馆里，对吧？教宗尤金四世授予科西莫一份赎罪诏书，这基本上就像是对他罪过的赦免。科西莫把它挂在圣器室的门上方。好让每个人都记住，你知道的，这一切都是我出资的，因此我已经免于罪孽。太妙了。
He very famously gets a friar there called Fra Angelico to paint kind of mystical frescoes in every monk's cell. And if you go to Florence and you go and see, I mean, these are some of the most amazing of all the artistic sites you will see in Florence. And actually we'll come back to this monastery, as this monastery ends up being the power base of Gerolimo Savonarola later in the series. But obviously art's not just about your soul, it's also about your status. Great example is the Palazzo Medici.
众所周知，他在那里找了一位名叫安杰利科修士的修士，在每个修士的单间里画了那种神秘的壁画。如果你去佛罗伦萨参观，我的意思是，这些将是你能在佛罗伦萨看到的、最令人惊叹的艺术景点之一。事实上，我们稍后会回到这座修道院，因为这座修道院在节目后面成了吉罗拉莫·萨沃纳罗拉的大本营。但显然，艺术不仅关乎你的灵魂，也关乎你的地位。美第奇宫就是一个很好的例子。
They got an architect called Michelozzo to do this in the 1440s. And this is another sort of temple to Renaissance art that Cosimo had made. It's a cross between, if you go to it today, it's a cross between the kind of Gothic fortress and a classical palace. So it has kind of Doric and Corinthian columns, very Renaissance. And then if you went in under the arcades, again very Renaissance, under the arcades, there would be classical busts, there would be loads of artworks, and particularly two of the most famous of all Renaissance artworks made by one of Cosimo's absolute favorites who's a man called Donatello, a sculptor. And these are both on biblical themes.
他们在15世纪40年代请了一位名叫米开洛佐的建筑师来做这件事。这也是科西莫建造的又一座文艺复兴艺术圣殿。如果你今天去参观，它介于哥特式堡垒和古典宫殿之间。所以它有类似多立克柱和科罗纳式柱，非常具有文艺复兴风格。然后如果你走进柱廊下方，同样非常具有文艺复兴风格，柱廊下方会有古典半身像、大量的艺术品，尤其是文艺复兴时期最著名的两件艺术品，它们出自科西莫绝对最喜欢的雕塑家多纳泰罗之手。这两件作品都是以圣经为主题的。
So there's David, the Old Testament hero. And he's kind of very young and kind of slightly girlish looking in that one, isn't he? So not like the Michelangelo one. No, and the other is Judith and Holofernes. They're biblical themes, but the style is classical. And the David is the first freestanding nude male sculpture since antiquity. So it's both retro and very modern. Cutting edge. Cutting edge because it's made from bronze, and bronze casting was so expensive that only the really, really super rich could afford to pay for it. So it really is the kind of bauble that a kind
这里有大卫，旧约中的英雄。那一尊里的他看起来非常年轻，甚至有点像女孩子，对吧？不像米开朗琪罗的那尊。是的，另一尊是朱迪斯与霍勒费尔内斯。它们是圣经主题，但风格是古典的。而且那尊大卫是自古代以来第一尊独立站立的男性裸体雕塑。所以它既复古又非常现代。极具前沿性。之所以前沿，是因为它是用青铜制成的，而青铜铸造非常昂贵，只有真正、真正的超级富豪才负担得起。所以它确实就像是那种……
of an Elon Musk or a Jeff Bezos or whoever, there's somebody of that ilk. So there's Donatello and the other big artist who's associated with this building is the painter. He's a great character actually. He's the friar, Filippo Lippi. So he's a friar, but he's also just an absolutely obsessive lecher. So Filippo Lippi will be doing his artworks and whatever and he's sitting there and then he suddenly, oh, I've got to go. He's overcome by lust and he has to leave. This happens all the time and Giorgio Vasari in his Lives of the Great Artist says that basically eventually Cosimo had to lock him in his room and say, look, come on, sort yourself out. Like finish the painting.
类似于埃隆·马斯克、杰夫·贝佐斯或别的什么人，那种级别的人会拥有的炫耀资本。所以这就是多纳泰罗，而与这座建筑相关的另一位大艺术家则是这位画家。其实他是一个很棒的人物。他是个修士，但同时也是一个绝对痴迷于女色的色鬼。菲利普·利皮有时在做他的艺术品或者别的什么，正坐在那儿，然后突然就说："哦，我得走了。"他被欲望冲昏了头脑，不得不离开。这种情况经常发生，乔治·瓦萨里在他的《艺苑名人传》中说，基本上最后科西莫不得不把他锁在房间里，对他说："听着，行了，把你自己理理清楚。把画画完。"
Cut off his internet connection. Right, but Lippi was so obsessed. He cut up his own bed sheets and made the rope so that he could climb out to go and visit a prostitute because he was so overcome by lust. And this is a friar. I mean, come on, you can't tell me that Thomas Cromwell wasn't onto something, Tom. Anyway, so the Palazzo Medici is not finished till the 1480s. But by that point, Cosimo was long dead. So in the 1450s, so by that point, what is he? 60s? His health had entered a decline and this will be a great theme of the series and this is gout.
切断他的互联网连接。没错，但利皮实在是太着迷了。他把自己床单剪碎做成绳子，这样他就能爬出去找妓女，因为他被欲望折磨得无法自拔。而这可是一个修士。拜托，得了吧，你不能告诉我托马斯·克伦威尔的看法没有道理，汤姆。不管怎样，美第奇宫直到15世纪80年代才完工。但到那时，科西莫早就去世了。所以在15世纪50年代，当时他几岁？60多岁？他的健康状况开始恶化，这将是本系列的一个重大主题，也就是痛风。
We love a bit of gout in the show. I think there were two great ages of gout. So one of them is Medici Florence and the other is kind of 18th century British gentleman's gloves. And this is one of them. Cosimo has terrible gout and he has to be carried everywhere. And he basically says to his sons, Piero and Giovanni, look, you guys are going to have to manage this, the Medici interest.
我们节目里对痛风可谓情有独钟。我想痛风曾有过两个鼎盛时期。其中一个美第奇家族统治下的佛罗伦萨，另一个则是18世纪英国绅士的手套。而这就是其中之一。科西莫患有严重的痛风，无论去哪儿都得让人抬着。他基本上对他的儿子们皮耶罗和乔瓦尼说："听着，伙计们，你们得来打理美第奇的产业了。"
Piero, you do the politics, Giovanni, you do the bank. Unfortunately, they also have horrendous gout. So this one day, when a bloke turned up at the Palazzo Medici to meet Cosimo, and he found them all lying in bed, presumably together, all groaninganing with that gout which was obviously a ludicrous scene. They might bump into one another and that's Unbearably painful if you have gout in bed, but I think they're probably lying very rigidly I don't know. I don't know how you lie in gout You don't want to share a bed with someone if you've got go I don't think no I wouldn't anyway Well gout is a serious business now. I don't know. We shouldn't be laughing about it. We're punching down Tom. Poor. I'm not laughing. I'm being sympathetic.
皮耶罗，你负责政治；乔瓦尼，你负责银行。不幸的是，他们也患有可怕的痛风。所以有一次，当一个家伙来到美第奇宫拜访科西莫时，他发现他们全都躺在床上，大概是一起躺着的，都在因痛风而呻吟，那显然是一个荒唐的场面。他们可能会撞到彼此，如果你在床上患有痛风，那将是难以忍受的痛苦，但我认为他们大概躺得非常僵挺。我不知道。我不知道你痛风时是怎么躺的。如果你得了痛风，你可不想和别人同床共枕，我想不会，反正我不会。好吧，痛风现在可是件大事。我不知道。我们不应该取笑它。汤姆，我们在欺负弱势群体。真可怜。我没在笑。我在表示同情。
Giovanni, he died very young. Well, quite young. He died at 42 with his gout. Some historians say because of kidney failure, gout related. Others say he was unbelievably fat and he probably had a heart attack. Anyway, either way he's dead. Giovanni was Cosimo's favorite and he's very depressed at this and never really recovers. And actually just under a year later in August 1464 Cosimo died probably of gout related kidney failure. And he had a big funeral. He was buried in the Medici Church at San Lorenzo. And the Signore gave him the title, Pata Patrii, Father of his Country. And Tom, you will know who had this before. Cicero had it and Augustus had it.
乔瓦尼，他很年轻就去世了。嗯，相当年轻。他带着痛风在42岁时去世了。一些历史学家说是因为肾衰竭，与痛风有关。另一些人说他胖得不可思议，可能心脏病发作了。不管怎样，反正他死了。乔瓦尼是科西莫最疼爱的儿子，科西莫对此非常沮丧，从此再也没有真正恢复过来。事实上，就在不到一年后的1464年8月，科西莫去世了，死因大概也是与痛风有关的肾衰竭。他举行了盛大的葬礼。他被埋葬在圣洛伦索的美第奇教堂里。领主共和国授予他"国父"的称号。汤姆，你知道之前谁拥有过这个称号吗？西塞罗拥有过，奥古斯都拥有过。
Exactly. Exactly. And it's the title, the words are inscribed on his tomb. And of course, he, with this being a fan of Cicero and of Augustus, he would have absolutely loved it. Do you think it would have consoled him as he stood in the burning sand? No, you again, you're displaying your irreligiosity because the Pope explicitly said that God loved a fresco and that God loved all this stuff. So there's no burning sand that's not
没错。完全正确。这个称号，这些字被刻在了他的墓碑上。当然，作为西塞罗和奥古斯都的崇拜者，他一定会对此喜爱至极。你觉得当他站在炽热的沙子中时，这能安慰到他吗？不，你又在表现你的不虔诚了，因为教宗明确说过上帝喜欢壁画，上帝喜欢所有这些东西。所以根本没有什么炽热的沙子……
in the equation. So Cosimo is now dead. But where does this leave the Medici and where does it leave Florence? Well, I will give the last word to one of his opponents, who's a patrician called Marco Parenti. And he said after Cosimo's death, he said, not for many years had Florence been so prosperous. But on his death, everyone rejoiced, such was their love and desire for liberty. It appeared to the Florentines that Cosimo's style of government had brought them to subjection and servitude. And from this, they believed that his death would liberate them.
在公式里。所以科西莫现在已经去世了。但这把美第奇家族置于何地，又把佛罗伦萨置于何地呢？好吧，我把最后发言权留给他的一个反对者，那是一个名叫马尔科·帕伦蒂的贵族。他在科西莫死后说，他说，佛罗伦萨已经有很多年没有如此繁荣过了。但在他死后，人人都感到欢欣鼓舞，可见他们对自由是多么热爱和渴望。佛罗伦萨人觉得科西莫的统治风格使他们陷入了臣服与奴役。由此，他们相信他的死会解放他们。
But Dominic, will it? And I'm guessing that in the next episode, we will be finding out and we will be exploring the life and times of the most celebrated, the most glittering, in fact, the most bloodstained of all the Medici, Lorenzo the Magnificent. Is that right? Yes, I can't wait. And you know what? Not only can I not wait, but I'm guessing a lot of the listeners can't wait.
但是多米尼克，会吗？我猜在下一集中，我们将拭目以待，并将探索美第奇家族中最著名、最耀眼、实际上也是血债最多的一个人的一生与时代——"伟人"洛伦佐。是这样吗？是的，我已经迫不及待了。你知道吗？不仅我迫不及待，我猜许多听众也已经迫不及待了。
And is there any way, Tom, that Renaissance men and women could hear that now? Absolutely there is, Dominic, because like the Medici, we have set up a very convenient banking system at restishistory.com where people can hear that episode and the next two episodes, three episodes of unbelievable value. Yeah. And so I want to say God wants you to do it and you will not go to hell if you join the rest of the history club. That is the most important thing to emphasize.
汤姆，文艺复兴时期的男男女女有没有什么办法现在就能听到那一集？当然有，多米尼克，就像美第奇家族一样，我们在restishistory.com上建立了一个非常便利的银行系统，人们可以在那里收听那一集以及接下来两集，总共三集内容精彩绝伦的节目。是的。所以我想说，上帝希望你这么做，只要你加入"历史其余部分"俱乐部，你就不会下地狱。这是最需要强调的事情。
Make God happy. Unbelievable value and on that note, thank you Dominic and ciao. Ciao. I'm Gordon Carrera and I'm David McClaskey together with the co-host of another Goal Hanger show called The Rest is Classified. Here's that clip we mentioned earlier on. When I look back on it now, you still see that, you know, there's plans, there's memoranda, there's notifications, there's all these things, but they're never actually
让上帝高兴。内容精彩绝伦，说到这里，谢谢你，多米尼克，再见。再见。我是戈登·卡雷拉，我是大卫·麦克拉斯基，我们是另一个由Goalhanger制作的节目《真相皆机密》的联合主持人。以下是我们之前提到的那段剪辑。当我如今回看时，你依然会发现，你知道的，有计划、有备忘录、有通知，有所有这些东西，但它们从来没有真正……
executed. They never actually kind of pull the trigger on anything, do they? I'm a little bit of two minds on this because I agree with you that the theme of this episode really is a series of missed opportunities to get Osama bin Laden prior to 9-11. Yeah. But we should also note that once Tenet and the CIA understand that Osama bin Laden is coming for us, in particular after the East Africa bombings, there is a push to improve our collection and our understanding of al-Qaeda pretty significantly. I mean, there's a bunch of human sources who get recruited in this period. There's a lot more technical collection. Alex station is beefed up to more than 40 people.
真正付诸行动过，对吧？对于这一点我有点举棋不定，因为我同意你的看法，这一集的主题实际上是9-11事件之前错失了一系列抓捕本·拉登的机会。是的。但我们也应该注意到，一旦特尼特和中情局明白本·拉登是冲着我们来的，特别是在东非爆炸案之后，各方就开始大幅度改善我们对基地组织的搜集和理解。我的意思是，这一时期招募了一批人类情报来源。有了更多技术搜集手段。亚历山大情报站的规模被充实到40多人。
There's a bunch of connections with foreign partners on Al Qaeda that hadn't existed before. I mean, interestingly, there's a PDB president's daily brief in December, December the 4th of 1998, which is titled quote Bin Laden preparing to hijack US aircraft and other attacks. And so there's a lot of. December, December the fourth of 1998, which is titled quote, Bin Laden preparing to hijack US aircraft and other attacks. Yeah. So there's a lot of strategic warning, I think you could say about what Al Qaeda is up to.
建立了一批过去不存在的、与外国伙伴关于基地组织的联系。我的意思是，有趣的是，在1998年12月，也就是1998年12月4日，有一份总统每日简报，其标题是引述"本·拉登正准备劫持美国飞机和其他袭击"。所以有很多。1998年12月，也就是1998年12月4日，有一份总统每日简报，其标题是引述"本·拉登正准备劫持美国飞机和其他袭击"。是的。所以对于基地组织在搞什么鬼，我想你可以说有很多战略预警。
And yet there's an inability, I think, to translate that into practical efforts and operations to stop these attacks and stop Al-Qaeda from ultimately carrying out 9-11. If you want to hear the full episode, listen to the rest is classified wherever you get your podcasts. Hi everybody, you're still here. Right at the end of the episode, I'm very impressed by your commitment. But listen, I have a question for you. I want to ask you something in confidence. Do you sometimes listen to the adverts on these episodes?
然而，我认为人们无法将这一点转化为切实的努力和行动，以阻止这些袭击，并阻止基地组织最终实施9-11事件。如果你想收听完整节目，请在各大播客平台收听《真相皆机密》。大家好，你们还在。在节目快结束的时候，我对你们的执着印象深刻。但是听着，我有个问题想问你们。我想私下问你们一件事。你们有时会听这些节目里的广告吗？
And do you sometimes think, do you know what? I wish that the listeners to this podcast, I wish they were listening to an advert about my brand rather than the other stuff that Tom and Dominic are promoting on here. If you have thought that, there is of course, only one way to find out what that would be like. You can disrupt the procession of adverts. You could be the next HSBC premiere or the many other tremendous companies that have advertised on the rest is history. And you could put your brand in front of millions of like-minded listeners
你们有时会想，你知道吗？我希望这个播客的听众听到的不是汤姆和多米尼克在这里推广的其他东西，而是关于我的品牌的广告。如果你有过这种想法，当然只有一种方法能知道那会是什么感觉。你可以打破广告的常规流程。你可以成为下一个汇丰银行卓越理财（HSBC Premier），或是曾在《历史的其余部分》上做过广告的许多其他了不起的公司之一。你可以将你的品牌展示给数百万志同道合的听众
by advertising on the rest is history and indeed the other shows on the Goalhanger Network. Now you may be thinking, I don't know what the Goalhanger Network is. Goalhanger are the company behind this very show. And if you are in the market to increase the value of your brand, Goalhanger would love to hear from you. You can register your interest or indeed your company's interest by going to Goalhanger.com right now. And that is Goal, G-O-A-L, Hangar, H-A-N-G-E-R, dot com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
通过在《历史的其余部分》以及Goalhanger网络旗下的其他节目上投放广告。现在你可能在想，我不知道什么是Goalhanger网络。Goalhanger就是制作这个节目的公司。如果你正打算提升你的品牌价值，Goalhanger非常乐意听到你的声音。你可以立即访问Goalhanger.com登记你的意向，或者你公司的意向。网址是Goal，拼写是G-O-A-L，Hangar，拼写是H-A-N-G-E-R，点com。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。